by now you checked into
registration to receive your
badge.
It must be visibly warn at all
times and you'll need it to
enter the after hours activities
at the end of days 1 and 2.
Throughout the event, make sure
to visit Google.com /IO.
Or download the IO Mobile App
for the most up-to-date
schedules and conference map.
For questionser on assistance,
stop by the information desk
looked across from the code labs
building or Chat with a staff
member wearing a yellow badge.
Sessions will take place in the
amphitheater and at the 8 stages
throughout the venue.
If you haven't already, reserve
a seat on the website or Mobile
App.
If you miss a session,
rasheddings will be available on
line shortly after they end.
Be sure to visit the code labs
building for hands on experience
with ready to code kiosks and
self-paced tutorials.
Google staff will be on hand for
helpful advice and to provide
direction if you need support.
Make some time to visit the
office hours and App reviews
tent to meet one-on-one with
Googlers, ask all your technical
questions and get feedback on
your projects F you're looking
to network with googlers and
fellow developers, join one of
the several meet ups hosted in
the community lounge.
Finally we'd like to visit you
to visit
the san box where you can
explore, plane and play with our
latest products and platforms
and demos and physical
installations and more.
After sessions are done for the
day, stick around for food,
drinks and music and fun and be
prepared for surprises along the
way.
We would like to take this
opportunity
to remind you you wu are
dedicated to providing an
inclusive event experience for
everyone.
And you agree to our Code of
Conduct posted throughout the
venue.
Your opinion is valuable to us.
After the event, look on the fur
feedback form to share your
experience.
Thank you for attending and have
a
wonderful time exploring Google
I/O
.
H.
welcome and thank you for
joining.
Our session will begin soon.
>> AYLIN ALTIOK: Hello,
everyone.  We are really Excited
to have you all here today.
My name is Aylin and I'm a
Product Manager for Actions on
Google.
>> NICK FELKER: I'm a developer
of programs engineer and Google
Assistant and IoT.
>> AYLIN ALTIOK: Today we will
talk about Best Practices for
testing your actions and tools
we have built to make it easier
for you.  But before getting
into details, I
want to mention why testing is
so important.  It's important
because your users care about
it.
How do we know that?
By looking at play reviews, we
noticed
42% of the users mention
stability and
box in their 1 star review.
And 62% of the users uninstall
the App
if they notice crash, freeze or
an error.
On the flip side, though, 73% of
the users mention speed, design
and
usability in their 5-star
review.
So this tells us users want
5-star Apps.
And this has been the trend we
have been seeing in mobile
world.
And it's no different when it
comes to Actions.
So today, we will walk you
through some tips and tools that
will let you build your own
5-star Actions.
Our journey today starts with
Jane.  Jane is a developer.  She
works on a start-up and she
wants
to build her own Action.  Her
Action is called TrailBlazer.
And TrailBlazer will return
nearby
bike trails for a given user
location.
So, together, we'll start our
journey designing and building
TrailBlazer with Dialogflow.
Then we will test it locally by
using simulator.
And we will show you how you can
write
your own unit test for your
Actions by
using automated testing library.
And we'll show you how you can
test your
Actions with your own users by
using balta release
environments.
This is something we just
announced yesterday and we are
super excited to
show you the details later today
in this session.
And we'll show you some tools
like analytics and set driver
logging to make
sure your actions remain healthy
throughout life cycle.
Awesome!  Let's start with
design and build.  So we will do
that with Dialogflow.
Dialogflow enables you to build
rich conversational experiences.
How does it do that?
It gives you natural language
processing out-of-the-box.
So it takes user response and it
automatically match that to
intense and entities you
defined.
And you can handle this in your
own server.
So as a developer, you don't
need to worry about knowing or
writing your own mission
learning models.  It just works
for you if you use Dialogflow.
Let's see what it means for
TrailBlazer.
So as you can see, Dialogflow
sits in
between a system server and your
own server.
So for TrailBlazer we use Google
Cloud Platform to build our own
server logic.
When user says talk to
TrailBlazer,
assistant server takes that
response and takes our welcome
intent from Dialogflow and
returns back to  user.
So after that point, user may
say, find
me a nearby bike trail or where
are the nearby bike trails, and
multiple other variations of
these type of text responses.
And then, Dialogflow
automatically match that to
intent we defined.
Let's call it, find trails, and
that intent may be reading the
logic from our own server.  Our
own server may have the location
services, we find the trails,
and we respond back to user.
And we don't need to worry about
natural language processing.>>
NICK FELKER: Thank you.  So now
you built your Action.  How do
you start testing it?  The first
step is to use the Actions on
Google simulator.
And this works on your laptop or
desktop and also test on your
device if you have a home or a
phone.  You can enter text or
you can just
talk to it and you'll get the
response you expect.  And you
can do extra things like
changing the user's language and
their location.
How does this work?
Let's go to the demo.
Let's go to the demo.  Click on
the simulator tab, here.
We will jump right here into the
Action.
Rewill say, talk to TrailBlazer.
We can say, find trails nearby.
You notice I did make a typo
there but Dialogflow will be
able to map it to the intent,
regardless.
And we have a request and
response tab
on the side and that will help
you to debug your Actions.
We'll say yes.  Share the
location.
Notice in the top right corner,
I mapped it to my hometown.
So you can actually show the
different types of locations as
well.
And then display tab, notice it
has picked a park that is pretty
close to
where I used to live.  And
that's a very basic overview of
how the simulator works.
Let's go back to the Slides for
a second.
So, you can do this and mainly
test your Actions every time you
make a change.  But as Actions
grow more complicated, you want
to make sure that users continue
to have a reliable experience.
And to make this easier, we are
introducing the automated
testing library for Actions on
Google.
If you're familiar with - node
JS, then you will be familiar
with this testing library.  It
supports all the Actions on
Google low calls and works with
your existing testing
infrastructure, whether that is
a lender or continuous
integration.  All those things
work out-of-the-box.
So, there is three key features
this library le do for
developers.  First, you can send
text queries to your  Action.
This can be unstructured
queries, exactly what the user
would  say.  And this is
important because users can say
anything to your conversation.
And you want to make sure you
can handle that.
You're going to get SSML, text,
rich responses and everything
else you would expect.
And this is your account to send
the queries.  So things like
user storage and the
last time you visited the
Action, will
be exactly what it would be for
yourself.
How is this going to work for
you as a developner let's switch
over to the demo and I'll show
you.
So you notice I have this test
DJS
file here and we will go down
here.
First we import the library and
we will pass in my user
credentials so it will talk to
this Action as  myself.  And we
start a test.  And we get a test
name.
We can also set thick like the
location.  So we can change the
location and see how the Action
performance in different areas.
Then we will start by returning
a promise that will start the
conversation with TrailBlazer.
We'll go and send this query,
find trails nearby.
And then we will send yes after
it asks for our location.
You make sure you also try no
and test different flows with
different permissions.  At the
very end, we will get back text
to speech and cards.  And you
can do a search to verify those
are exactly what we expect.  At
the very  end, you end the test.
How does this work?
Let's go over here and run MPM
test.
Okay, so now we  started our
In a few seconds, it is going to
send, talk to TrailBlazer.  And
we will get back a response.
Okay.
And you see a variety of
parameters in that response.
Text to speech, SSML cards, et
cetera.  So we send, find trails
nearby.  We will get back that
thing that Google will ask for
permission to use our location.
We'll say, yes.
And then at the end, you see you
got the card, you got the text
and everything else from our
Action.
At the bottom, it says one test
passes.  There you go.
So using this tool, you will be
able
to more easily verify that your
Actions do exactly what you
expect.
So let's switch back to the
Slides.
>> AYLIN ALTIOK: Awesome. So
far we will TrailBlazer and we
tested it locally in our
simulator.
And we wrote our own unit test
and make sure they were all
green.  But it is always
important, as a developer, to
test your Actions with your own
users.  Why?  Because they may
find bugs and usability issues
that you didn't think or you
didn't catch.
Let's see how you can do it by
utilizing
our new, Alpha and Beta release
environments.
So Alpha is the quickest way to
test your Actions.  Once you
submit Alpha, it doesn't go
through the review process.
So it can be live live just in
couple hours.  And you can
invite your friends, family and
teammates up to 20 testers.
And you  caniterate by releasing
Alpha and acting on the feedback
from your users and keep this
iteration going on
until you have the stable
version.
And once you have the stable
version, you can submit that for
Beta release.
Beta is live after going through
regular Google review process.
So your Actions would be live if
they are approved after the
review.  But once they are
approved, you don't need to go
through additional review to
deploy those to production.
So as a developer, you can
decide when
to deploy this to public
audience at your own flexible
timing.
And you can invite wider
audience for
your Beta release up to 200
users.  Awesome.  Let's see how
that works in Action.
Let's go back to demo mode.
Perfect.  So let's take it from
where we left off in simulator.
So now you can see a new release
tab in the left hand side
navigation in the Actions
console.  Let's click that.  And
you will see aside from
production, we also have now
Alpha and Beta release.  These
are totally optional.  You don't
need to utilize those but since
you're in the session today, I'm
sure you care about testing your
actions with your own users.
And before getting into the
details of Alpha, I just want to
show you the versions I already
deployed before.
So currently, I have three
different versions one in Alpha,
one in Beta and one in
production that is already
deployed to my users.
So let's go ahead and deploy an
Alpha together.  But before
doing so, let's change something
in our Actions so we can tell
our users if they like the new
change.
So now you see the actions under
the build section.  I'll go
ahead and click that.
And if you are family with the
-- familiar with the Action
console, we just redesigned the
whole UI for you to make it
easier for your navigation.
So we will see our default
welcome intent here that we
already built with Dialogflow.
I'll click to that and it gives
me option to edited that in
Dialogflow.  Let's see how that
looks like.  So this is my
welcome intent.  But we also
have other intent that is I
mention to you before that we
can handle in our server.
So I'll go back and go to
default welcome intent.  So
right now, our welcome message
to
the users says good day from
TrailBlazer.
Let's change that and let's see
if our Alpha testers would like
it.
So instead of TrailBlazer, let's
say,
good day from Google I/O Stage
7.
So, I'll save this, and after it
is
saved, I can go ahead and see
how that works by clicking
right-hand side.
And this is going to bring my
draft version into the simulator
to see the change that is I just
did.  So let's see.
Talk to TrailBlazer.
Let's make sure it is reading
from the draft.
Let's try it again.  Awesome.
So it says, good day from Google
I/O Stage 7, as we expected.  So
we want to test it with our
Alpha users and see if they are
going to like this response
instead of the previous version.
And also please note that you
can see
all your versions here and test
them to see the difference.
So I'll just click down and go
ahead and
click on the release tab now.
And on the release tab, let's
push this version into our Alpha
testers.  So while my production
and Beta
remains like a different welcome
that
says, welcome to TrailBlazer,
our Alpha will be taking this
version and changing the welcome
response.  So we just need to
click that we
tested it in simulator.  We gone
through the check list and
complying with policies.
And once we submit, this is
going to
run our checks and will be done
in few seconds.
And while it is doing that -- it
is already done.
So you can see now that our
version will be deploying state.
Perfect.
So we created version 7, and now
it is being in the deploying
state and it will be deployed
just in few hours and live to
your testers.
But how do we invite our own
testers?  You'll see a manage
Alpha testers and same applies
to Beta, by the way.  The only
difference with Beta, we would
see the status as, under review.
So we'll go ahead and click on
manage testers.  So in this
section, you can add your own
testers to make sure they are
white listed to receive your
Alpha version.
So we can add just --ed that to
my list and I already had some
other e-mails before.  And once
I hit save, all of these
users are white listed to get my
Alpha version.  Just couple
things to note here.
The users you're adding should
have a
Google account, either Gmail or
Google Maps user otherwise you
would see that it will fail and
you can remove and add new
users.
So, the last step as a developer
for  you, is to invite your own
testers.
So you see here there is an
opt-in link.  And this is static
link that directs
users to your directory page.
So if you're users already using
your
Action in their mobile, they can
just search your Action name
like, TrailBlazer, and they
would see your invitation in the
Action directed page.  But if
they are not familiar with that,
you can just share this link and
once they click this link on
their mobile phone, either iOS
or Android, they would land into
your directory.
Let's see how that experience
looks  like.
Let's go back to our Slides.
Perfect.
We now created an Alpha release
and we took the opt-in link and
shared with our tester.  So the
first screen here is the place
they landed.
So this is my Action directory
page on mobile.
And when they scroll down, they
see
that the invitation that I added
them to
my Beta -- or same applies to
Alpha.
Once they are all okay to be
your Alpha tester, they say, I'm
in.  And after that point, they
will start talking to your test
version.
At any time, they can opt-out or
they can switch between Alpha
and Beta if you
invited them to both channels.
How cool is that?
This was something -- this
feature was a top developer
request and we are also excited
to actually make it happen.
So let's recap what we have been
doing so far.  So Jane builds
her TrailBlazer Action with
Dialogflow.  She tested locally
with simulator and also she was
able to test it with her
own device that was connected to
her preview account.
And she wrote her unit test by
using automated testing library.
And once everything was green,
she moved to her teammates and
made an Alpha release.  Her
teammates gave her feedback and
she was able toiterate and make
her actions more stable.
And then she released it to her
Beta testers to more wider
audience.
And once she made sure her
Actions are
stable, she is ready to go for
production.
But before going to production,
I would like to share some Best
Practices while
you are testing your actions.
So as a developer, we always
think about end-to-end journeys
and try to
capture those use cases in our
test.
But what does it even mean in a
conversational space?
So in a system world, your users
may be in multiple modes.
And these modes are determined
by
input and output of your device.
So if a user is talking to
TrailBlazer in Google Home, they
would only get voice.  But if
they are talking to TrailBlazer
on their mobile phone, not only
would they get voice, but they
would also get image of the
nearby bike trails.
So as a developer, it is
important to
think about where our users may
be interacting with our  actions
and handle these test cases
accordingly to make
sure their experience is smooth
in all
device that is actions are
offered.
And the second important point
is to
make sure your users are able to
answer your actions.  It's good
to test your invocations.
They can invoke your App in
multiple ways.
Either explicitly by saying,
talk to TrailBlazer.
Or you may also have some
built-intense or implicit
invocation that may be
triggereddered in different way.
Let's say, play a game.
Or find a nearby bike trail.
So Actions on Google today are
offered in multiple languages.
And it becomes even more
important to test your user's
languages in a conversational
world.
So this is a great one to be
able to
test programly by using unit
tests or in simulator as well as
you can offer your
Alpha and Beta environments to
the use they're speaks one of
these languages.
And see if they can navigate.
And same applies to location.
Today, Nick pointed out that in
simulator, you are able to
change the location and see how
your action responds back.
Actions on Google offers
multiple functional activities
to developers, like facilitated
payments, account
linking, reengagement, push
notifications.
Some of these may be hard to
test pragmatically.  For
example, let's take payment as
an example.
So this may be a perfect use
case to
test with your Alpha or Beta
testers and make sure that they
can get the
functionality that you want to
be.
And last but not least, our
Action may be touching into
multiple stack.
So TrailBlazer rebuilds not only
have
Dialogflow and assistance on the
client side but we also build
Orion server.  So it is
important to make sure and
handle all the cases in each of
these
text in the architecture.
>> NICK FELKER: So, you
designed, built and tested your
Action.  Now you deployed it to
users.  But it doesn't stop
there.  You have to continue to
ensure that users have a great
experience.  We have a couple of
tools to help you do that.  The
first of which is the Health
Analytics section in the
console.  And this we'll slow
you graphs for the number of
errors that users are
experiencing as well as the
latency.
And we do periodic checks on
your Action and if we determine
they are unhealthy, we will let
you know over an e-mail and if
it continues to be unhealthy, it
will be disabled until it
becomes healthy again.
Let's switch over to the demo.
So here we are in the analytics
page.
You can jump over to health and
see the errors that are
happening.  Let's go ahead and
jump over the last three months,
what kind of errors have we had?
You see there are a couple of
errors that  started out a few
weeks ago.  We can go ahead and
look at the errors themselves.
In valid response.  Time out.
Unknown error.  We can learn
more about why these errors
might be happening.
We can also filter these out and
say, okay, people might be
having a different
experience on a phone compared
to a Google Home.  And seems
like all these errors relate to
mobile devices.  We can also
look at the latency and
see 50% of users are getting
about 200  milliseconds.  That's
a pretty good response time.
As we jump out towards the 95
percentile, it gets higher and
so maybe we want to see what
kind of things are happening for
some of those users to help
reduce that latency.
And there is more graphs as
well.
Now the second part in making
sure you have reliable action is
Stackdriver.  To show you how to
do that, I'm going to go back to
the simulator.
And we talked about finding bike
trails.  But there is also a bug
in our Action.
So if I say, give me a tip.
It's going to crash.
That's intentional for this
demo.
So it says, final response must
be set.  You might have
experienced this when you're
using the simulator.  But you
might not know what this means.
Click this view logs button.
We'll jump into Stackdriver,
which is our log-in tool.  And
it will show all of these things
that happened, all the logs, for
our Action.  We can go ahead and
filter something like errors.
So we'll find all the errors
that happened.
You see right now we just got
this final
response must be set.  It is a
lot of information here.  What
does this mean?
Since we are using
CloudFunctions, we actually also
logged what is happening there
as well.
And we have this error in our
Cloud function T says, reference
error, trail
tips is not defined  index.JS
line 30.
Okay, let's jump over to our
code and figure out what is
happening.  Index.
JS line 30 says -- this is
actually  correct.  Okay.
So you might see that there is a
syntax error in our index.JS
file.  Once you figure out this
is a problem,
we can go ahead and make the
change and
do another deploy.
And then the next time we run
our tool and through the
simulator or testing, it will
work as we expect.  So let's
jump back to the Slides and
recap what just happened.
So with Stackdriver Logging, you
can examine error logs for your
fulfillment
and filter these logs based on
types of errors and anything
else that might be logging.  And
what is really cool is that no
custom code is required.  If
you're using Actions on Google,
you get those logs.  If you're
using CloudFunctions, you get
those logs as well.
>> AYLIN ALTIOK: Awesome. This
concludes our journey today.  So
let's review what we have been
doing together.
So it started with Jane and Jane
had an idea for an Action
called, TrailBlazer.
She built with Dialogflow.  Once
she was done with designing and
building, she moved it to her
simulator
and tested locally on her device
and on the simulator on the
Actions on Google web.  And then
she wrote her own unit test
by using automated testing
library.
And once it was all good and
tested, she released it to her
Alpha and Beta
testers to make sure she gets a
stable action.  And once she
gets that, she was able
to deploy to public, all systems
users.  And she was able to grow
her audience and she was able to
get more engagement.
Throughout this journey, once
her Action was in production,
she was able to monitor it by
looking at the Health
Analytics in Actions on Google
console, or Stackdriver Logging
that comes out-of-the-box.  And
she was able to check and
monitor
and catch the box if her
production users had been seeing
any issues.
So she was able to fix those and
make
sure her action was healthy.
As a result, Jane was able to
get her
own  5-star Actions.  And you
want to make sure that all the
tools and tips we shared today
will help you get your own
5-star Actions.  Thank you very
much for coming and we would
love to hear from you.  So if
you can go and provide us
feedback in this link up here,
we would be so happy.
And also, please visit Actions.
google.com if you want to learn
more about the things we talked
about today.
And Nick and I will be available
after
the session in sandbox if you
have any questions.
We would love to hear from you
either through our developer
challenges or in person in IO.
>> NICK FELKER: Make sure you
follow us on Twitter and follow
abses on Google
and use the #AOGDEVS.  Thank
you.
[ Applause ]
>> SANDEEP DINESH: What's up?
Good morning!  It's 9:30 and we
are all sleeping still.  Ubers
and traffic?  I know all the
excuses.  My name is Sandeep.
Today I want to talk to you
about
microservices with Kubernetes
and Istio.  So I'm a developer
advocate on the
Google Cloud working with
Kubernetes for the past three
years.
It's grown a lot.
And Istio is the next new hot
thing coming out so you're all
here to learn about it.  So
let's go.
Because we all know
microservices are awesome,
right?  When you have a
traditional application, like a
model, you have all your logic
in one App, right?  So a Java
App, Ruby App, node, whatever.
You would have all the code in
your one App.
It would do all the parts, maybe
using like object orientation so
have you different classes that
do different things.  But at the
end of the day, it's like one
big program that does all the
stuff.  And it's a lot of
advantages doing this monolithic
type of development.  The it's
easier to debug and easier to
deploy.  You just push it out
and you're done.  When you have
a small team, and you
have a small App, it's really
easy to do.
But the problem with the
monolith comes when your App
starts to grow a little bigger.
So now you have all of these
things and all these different
pieces but you still have one
App that is doing all of it,
right?  So any time you want to
make a change in invoicing, that
means you have to redeploy the
whole thing, even though the ETL
pipeline might not have been
affected at all and maybe the
invoicing part is really good to
be done in Java,
but ETL pipeline you want to use
Python and on the front end you
want to use NodeJS.
But if you have a monolithic
App, your stuck into using one
language.
A team that wants to make a
update to one part has to touch
the whole thing.  And things
start to get really Harry really
quickly.  So with microservices,
each one of these becomes its
own individual
component that can be written in
its own language and updated and
deployed independently of the,
so this gives you more agilitiy
and more flexibility and a lot
more speed and a lot more cool
things like that.
So you're like, that sounds
really good.  Why is anyone
using monolith?  Because once
you start growing even
bigger, it gets even more
complicated, right?
Honestly, a monolith can fall
apart at this point too but even
all the advantages of the
microservices start to get
really hard to manage because
now you don't have just 20
microservices, have you 2000
microservices, right?  And how
do you know which one talks to
which one and you the intricate
spider web of connections works?
You might have a single request
that comes into your load
balance they're
gets send to 20,000
microservices and all the way
back up and anywhere that chain
breaks your whole application
looks like it is broken.
So debugging this becomes super
hard.
Deploying things making sure
everything is in lock step with
each
other T becomes
really difficult to try to
manage this huge stack of
services.  So are microservices
terrible?
Maybe.  But we can use a lot of
tooling to try to make them more
manage believe.
So let's use tools to automate
the
infrastructure component and
automate the networking
components and the management
sides of things.  When you look
at a monolith versus
microservice, they have a lot of
complexity.  The difference is,
unless you know something I
don't, there is no tools out
there that umly write code for
you and maintain two million
Java line App.
It's like some magic AI to write
code, we all will be out of
years.  Maybe in a few years.
We have a lot of tools that can
automate infrastructure a lot
more easily.  So a lot of the
issues that we have
with microservice can be
automated away.
So let's take a look at some of
those tools.  So how many people
are familiar with Docker?  I
expect a lot of hands to go up.
So for those who are not
familiar with Docker, Docker is
basically a way to package your
application.
So it doesn't matter if you're
writing node code, Python, Java,
whatever.
Doesn't matter if you have image
magic, a random library, you put
it in your Docker container and
you're good to go.  All you have
to do is care about running the
container.  You don't have to
care about running what is
inside of it.
So basically you take your code
and your dependency and put it
into a generic container format.
It doesn't matter what is inside
as long as you can run a
container you can run all of
them.
So now you have a container.
You have to run it on your
cluster, right?  Because logging
into a single machine and then
running Docker run and then
doing that 1000 times, it seems
like a waste of time to me.  So
instead, we can use something
like Kubernetes which is a
container orchestration system.
And what we can do with that is
say say, run this container five
times somewhere in my cluster.
What it will do is it will run
your containers for you
automatically.
So let's say you wanted to run
this container and that
container and that one and you
want two copies of each.  You
just tell Kubernetes that and it
figures out how to run them.
The nice thing about this is if
a server crashes, it will figure
out that server crashed and run
them somewhere else.  If a
application crashes, it will
figure that out.  If you want to
scale it up, go from two copies
to four copies.  Say make it
four and it will spring up two
more.  Go down to one because
you want to save money, say hey,
make one and it will remove
three.
This is like a declarative
syntax that makes it really easy
to manage these containers
running on your cluster.  Mew
might have thousands running.
Doing it manually is impossible.
How many heard Kubernetes and
keep your hands up if you used
it before.  About half.
Cool.  But that is the starting
point.  Now you have these
containers running.
You have to manage the services
because you have container A
talking to container B and C and
D.  How do you manage that set
of points going between each
other?  How do you set rules on
who can talk to who?  Who can
talk to what?  How many tries
should you have?  How much
network traffic should you send?
It becomes really complicated
and that is where Istio comes
into play.  It's a service mesh
which at the end of the  day, it
means that it manages your
services and the connections
that they make between
themselves.
So if you look at it, you take
orchestration and we go to
management and communication.
So you want to manage how these
services interact with each
other because that is what
really causes microservices to
be so useful, is the
communication between each
other.  You can reuse one
service that can talk to three
different ones with the same
information and mix-and-match
and do all of these really
powerful things but it becomes
hard to really understand what
is happening and Istio makes it
a lot easier to understand what
is
happening and control what is
happening.
All right.  So that's enough of
me  talking about random things.
Let's move to a demo.  If we can
go to that screen, thank you
very much.
And I can't see anything.  So
what we are going to do first --
go
back to the slides real quick.
Let me tell you what we are
going to do.
What we are going to do is walk
through
the end-to-end story of picking
an App and making it into a
microservice.  So we will take
an App, put it into a container,
run the container locally, store
the container on the Cloud and
then we'll create a Kubernetes
cluster and run our App on that
cluster and scale it out.  And
then we will do something more
interesting.  We will run
multiple Apps that work
together.  True microservices
pattern, and then monitor and
manage them with Istio.
Awesome.
Let's move back to the demo.
Cool.
So here I'm using Google Cloud
Shell.
It's a free VM in the Cloud that
let's you do your development
work.  I'm on a Chrome book
right now.
If it crashes, we will be like
jumping jacks until it comes
back or something.  I don't
know.  It happened before.
So, basically here I have some
code.  It's a little NodeJS
application.
If you don't know Java script,
that is fine.  It's a simple
App.
Basically it is a web server
that lift tones slash and it
will basically ping a
downstream.
So in this case, it will ping
here and it will make that
response and then send it to us.
So, let's run this locally right
now.
So if I go NPM start
, let's see what happens.  Cool.
So it's listening on port 3000.
So I will
so on Cloud Shell we can do a
web preview.  So it looks like
we are running a local machine.
You can see we go here and print
out our current test name and we
are seeing the current time.  If
I refresh this, the time will
change, right?  Cool.  So now
let's take this and put it into
a Docker container.
So to make a Docker container,
basically what we do is make
something called a Docker file.
So Docker file is a set of
instructions that creates this
end pointed.
Almost think of it like a bash
script it's what it is.
Here we start with node 8
Alpine.  Abyss image.  It give
us node stuff out of the bo box
and don't have to worry about
installing NodeJS and then we
copy in our  dependency and then
run.
Copy in our index code and
expose some ports and run MPM
start.  Once you run Docker
build, it will create a Docker
container.  So it let's build
and run that container.
For the sake of time I already
built it.
Here when I run that container,
once I built it -- nope.
I need to build it.
So it's just not found.  So this
might take a little bit of time.
And while we are building this,
let's switch to going and
building our Kubernetes Cluster.
So here in our Kubernetes -- if
I go
to Google Kubernetes engine,
Google Kubernetes engine is
Google's managed Kubernetes
offering.
So it is probably the easiest
way to create a
production-ready Kubernetes
Cluster.  Just click create
cluster and you get a bunch of
ones on what you can do to
create thisust whicher.
Go to name and description and
you can make it a zone at or
regional cluster and this is a
cool feature where you have
multiple masters so it is highly
available.  So if a zone goes
down, your cluster still will be
up and running.
You can choose the version of
Kubernetes you want, the size of
the cluster, and then a bunch of
not negative 21 -- let's not do
that.  You can do a lot of other
cool
features that Google Kubernetes
engine gives you out-of-the-box
like automatically upgrading
your nosed and repairing them if
they get broken.   Logging
monitoring, and a lot more too.
For example, auto-scaling.  You
can turn auto-scaling on which
means if you have more
containers that can fit in your
cluster, Google Kubernetes
engine will automatically scale
it up to create that space and
even better, if you have less
containers, will scale it down
to save you money, which is
really cool.
So a lot of that cool stuff.
And then all you have to do is
click, create, and it will
create thatust whicher.  So I'll
click cancer.  It's like a
cooking show.  We have one ready
in the oven.
This is still going.
That's okay.
What we'll do instead because I
have already built this and
pushed it.  So we will do the
opposite of what I
said and we will pull it down.
So I cheated but that's okay.
So let's run that container
locally.
So what we are going to do with
Docker is say, Docker run, and
then open up that port 3000.
And so if you look or go back
here, you can see that it is
basically the exact same thing.
Except now it is running in
Docker.  And so the really nice
thing is we didn't have to
change code.  Just put it into
the Docker container and we are
good to go, right?  Cool.
So, the next step is actually
pushing it to a container
registry.  The reason why we
have to do this is because we
can't just run containers
running on our local machine.
We have to push them to a secure
location so we can run them on
our cluster.  Google Container
registry is probably the best
place to put them 23 you're
running Kubernetes engine.
You get automatic
authentification and a few other
features we will look at in a
second.  Let's push it up.
That's not how you spell, make.
I love using make.  It makes
demos super easy.  So what we
are going to do is run Docker
push and -- can people read
that?  Or should I make it
bigger?  All right.  People can
read it.
So Docker push and then give the
name of the container.  So what
will happen is it will go to
Google Container
registry.  And so here in my
Istio test container, you can
see that we have the newest one
pushed up right now.  And it is
tagged as 1.0.
If I enabled it, one cool thing
it can do is vulnerability
scanning.
We can scan your containers for
known vulnerabilities
automatically for any
Alpine-based images.  That's
cool especially if you have
older containers if you haven't
updated in a while, go back and
look and you'll have tons of
vulnerabilities.  So it's a good
idea to check this out.  It's in
the Beta right now but it will
find a Burch of stuff wrong with
your things and tell you how to
fix them and then you just go
and update your containers and
you are good to go.
So it's a good thing running
older containers.  Now we have
this pushed up.  We can start to
deploy it to our Kubernetes
Cluster.  Like I said before, we
already have a cluster created.
Let's go back there.
Now basically to connect, we run
this command.  Let's run it.
Great.
So now we can say, cube  CTL, a
Kubernetes command line tool,
get nodes.  Just to make sure
everything is, working.
Is everything working?  A goody
request.  There it is.
We have a four-node Kubernetes
Cluster, running Version 1.9.7.
So now we can start running the
same contain they're we ran
locally.
So, what we are going to do is
do cube CTL run demo and then
give it the name of that image.
And demo will be the name of the
deployment that we are going
toet cra.
So if I say cube  CTL get
deployment, and then give that
name space.  It's just for this
demo's sake.
You don't need it in real life.
So you can see that we have our
demo
deployment created and if you
say, get pods, so pods are
basically the containers in
Kubernetes.
You can see that we have our
container created.  It's ready
and running.  But now that it is
running, you have to be able to
access it, right?  So this is
where it gets more complicated.
Where in the old world with
Docker, you access it directly
because it's running on your
local machine.  But in the
Kubernetes world it's running on
one of the four nodes and we
don't care which one.  We want a
static endpoint to route traffic
and access that node, right?
So, what we are going to do is
create a service.
And now I forgot what my make
command is.  That's okay.  I'll
look.  It's like a cheat sheet.
Let's see.  Expose.  There it
is.  Cool.
So what we'll do here is we'll
run cube CTL expose and then
we'll give it the target port of
3000 which is where our App is
listening, and then run it on
port 80, that's the normal HTP
port and we'll open a type load
balancer and give
us a public IP address using
Google Cloud load balancer.
Now, we can say, get service.
Most people here are familiar
with  Kubernetes.
If you're not familiar, talk to
me.  I know I'm going quickly,
but there is more exciting
things to happen soon.  So we
want to get to them.  So the
external IP address is pending.
Let's run a watch on that.  And
it's done the moment I try
anything complicated, it just
finishes.  It  knows.  Cool.
Let's go to that URL.
All right.
We'll just do this.
And if we go here, you can see
the
exact same App running on our
cluster.  So now we have it
running on our public IP
address.  If you go there on
your phone or laptop, it will
work.  And what we can do, let's
say all you go on your phone to
this IP address,
we'll probably overwomen this
App.
So in Kubernetes, we can scale
it out with the scale command.
So let's do that.
So let's say, cube CTL scale
deployment demo, the name of the
deployment, and then replicas
equals 5.
And again, that name space.
So it will say deployment demo
scaled.
So now if we go back to our get
pods, you'll notice we have five
of them running in our cluster,
which is really cool.
So, and then if we say, get
deployments,
you can see it also says that we
have five desired five current
and five up-to-date and five
available.  So now if we go back
to the IP address, it still
works.
The only difference is it is now
round Robinning traffic between
all five instances.  So you have
more scalability and a lot more
robustness and we are running
five copies even though we have
four VNs
because we are able to run
multiple
copies of on a single VN so we
get more
utilization out of our machines.
So, let's clean that up.  We no
longer need that demo.  Let's
start  looking at Istio.
So now we had a single service
running useless in the long
scheme of things.  No one just
runs one thing.  You don't need
Kubernetes to do that.  You want
to run multiple applications
together and make sure they all
work together well.
So what we are going to do is
run this same application three
times and then chain it
together.  So you might have
noticed in our code -- I'm going
to go back too it for a  second.
Basically, I can set whatever I
want as the upstream URI using
an environment variable.
So what I can do is actually tie
multiple of these together using
one to
talk to the other and talk to
the other and to tie them
together and then will all
concat mate their responses and
finally show at the end user.
So that's a really cool thing.
In Kubernetes we can dynamically
set these variables when
deploying.  So let's look at
that.
So normally in Kubernetes we
would create aiamil file.  I'm
going to make this bigger.  In
this file we will define our
deployments.
So I'm going to make four
So the first one will be called
front end prod.  So front end
production service.
I'm going to get the service
name, front end prod and the
upstream URI, I'm going to call
it, middleware.  So Kubernetes
will automatically do DNS-based
service discovery so I can find
my middleware application by
just pointing at middleware.
This is really cool.  I don't
need IP addresses or anything
like that.  You can see here
giving it  labels.  App front
end, version prod, and then the
same container name that we used
before.
And then in our middleware,
everything
looks the same except it is App
middleware version prod, and
then the service name is
different and the upstream URI
is now back end.  And then we
also have a canarr's version of
our middleware so like a test
version that is working on.  But
we want to see how it works in
the real world.
So again, this also points to
back end and then our back end
which points to time.JSON test.
com.
So, at this point, we can deploy
it into
our cluster.
So now we will create these
deployments but we also need to
create the corresponding
services so they can find each
other.  Let's take a look at
that.  So here in our  services.
iamil, it is straightforward.
We have a front end, middleware
and back end service.
They all open up port 3000 to
port 80, which makes sense.  The
only difference here is the
front end service is a type load
balancer so
that we get that public IP
address.  Cool.
So let's go to that public IP
address and see what happens.
Still pending.  That's fine.
Let's do it one more time.
There we go.
So interesting.  A little bit
different than before.  Our
front end prod went to our
middleware and then the
middleware went to our back end
and the back end went to time.
JSON  test.com.
But, we are getting a 404 which
is wierd because I mean if I go
to this website, clearly at the,
who.  We are seeing it working
all the time before.  It's
working.  So why are we getting
a  404?  And so now, we go into
the world of Istio.  So I have
Istio already running in this
cluster.  And what Istio will do
is really lockdown and help you
manage your microservices.
So it knows that time.JSON
test.com is a external service
and by default, it will block
all traffic going out of your
cluster.  And this is really
good for security reasons.  You
don't want your App talking to
random endpoints on the
internet.  You want as the
administrator to be able to
lockdown and only talk to
trusted endpoints.  So by
default everything is blocked
going out of your cluster.  So
how do you unblock it?
In Istio, we have something
called, egress rules.
It's a simple thing.  You can
see it is only like a few lines
ofiamil.  And so here we will
say allow traffic to time.JSON
test.
com so both port 80 for HTP and
for 443 for HTPS.
Let's deploy that rule.
And for I feltio we used the
Istio control command line tool.
It's just like the cube control
or cube CTL.
Istio CTL, I don't know how to
pronounce it.  Your guess is as
good as mine.  It's similar to
the cube control tool.  And so
now we have created that and we
can go back to our website and
hit refresh and you can see it
is all  working perfectly fine.
So we white listed traffic to
time.JSON test.com.
You might notice another thing
going on.
If I hit refresh, just look at
this line right here.  Sometimes
it says canary and sometimes it
says, prod.  Right?  And so the
reason why this is
happening is by default,
Kubernetes will use round Robin
load-balancing for services.  So
our middleware service is
pointing
to any deployment or any pod
that has a tag App middleware.
But both the canary and the prod
versions both have that tag.  So
Kubernetes will  blindly send
traffic to both.
In fact, if you had three
versions of canarr's and two
versions of your prod,
this traffic would go to canary
3-two because it's round
Robinning.  With Istio we can
make traffic go exactly where we
want.
Let's do that real fast.
We will set a route rule and
basically
send whenever the destination is
middleware, always send it to
prod.  And then whenever a
destination is front end send to
prod and back end send to prod.
Super simple things but what
happens is now hit refresh and
it will always go to our
production service.  So as an
end user, I never have to worry
about it.  I will always hit
production and won't hit some
random test build running in my
cluster, which is really nice.
But this is great.  This App is
like bulletproof.  It's soatism
it never breaks.
But in the real world, we have
our
code is not perfect.  I don't
write perfect code and neither
do you.  In the real world
things break all the time.  So,
to simulate that, I have this
really cool function called,
create issues.  And what create
issues will do is, it will look
at a header called, fail, and
then if that will generate a
number and if it is less than
that, it will just
return a 500.  Yes.  I didn't
know how else to make things
break on purpose.  It's hard to
make things break on purpose.
So this is a program called,
postman and if you never used it
before, it is awesome.
It let's you said headers in
JSON and things like that
automatically.  Let's do a
normal request right now.
It works the same Wayz as the
request
from the web browser but now we
can send
headers from the tool and let's
set a value of 0.3.  So 30%
chance of failure.  Let's see
what happens.  Boom.  Back end
failed.
Boom, middleware failed.
Everything worked.  Back end
failed again.
Everything worked again.
Middleware failed.  Everything
failed.  Right?  And you might
notice that the problem is worse
than we think because in our
code what we are doing is we are
propagating these headers.
These are for tracing.  We'll
take a look at that in a second.
We are forwarding this fail
header along each request.
So it's not just a 30% chance,
it's a 30% times 30% times 30%
chance of failure.  And that is
where all of this cascading
failures coming into play with
microservices because one
failure truggers tons of
failures downstream.
So let's take a look at how
Istio can help with this.
So let's do our second routing
rules.  Let's do something
called, a simple retry policy.
So let's have Istio
automatically retry the request
three times before giving up.
And again, we don't have to
change our code at all.  Istio
is transparently proxying all of
these network calls.  Proxying
is a strong word.
Transparently managing all these
network calls.  So what happens
is, our code doesn't
have to know it all that Istio
is trying it three times.  It
just tries it once and Istio
manages all the backoff and
retries and all that stuff for
you automatically.  So you don't
have to.  So now if we go back
to postman, let's see what
happens.  Boom.  Working.
Working.  Working.  Still some
issues.  Working.  Working.
Working.  Working.  Much better.
Obviously it didn't fix the
issue.  In fact, if I increased
this to something like version
0.
5, you can see it's going to
fail a lot more, or not.  It
might not fail.  It might mask
that.  You know what?  0.
0.9.  See.  Failure.  And you
might notice it is failing a lot
at the front too.  Right?
So let's take a look at two
things.
One, it's able to mask your
failures but you don't want it
to always do that, right?  Just
because things are working
doesn't mean things are good.
You want to be able to detect
that you have errors and be able
to detect that and fix it.  So,
Istio actually gives you a lot
of tooling out of the bo box to
manage your systems.  So first
thing I want to show you is
something called service graph.
So because Istio is sitting and
interSeptemberring the network
calls it is able to create a
full picture of your services
for you.  So you can see here we
have a front
end talking to a prod in
canarr's back end and talking to
time.JSON test.com.
We can also start doing things
automatically getting metrics
from our cluster as well.  Wow,
that looks way too zoomed in.
All right.  Let's zoom out a
little bit.  You can see here
once we started adding those
errors our global success rated
just started  crashing to the
bottom.  And so Istio will
automatically find
your 500s, 400s, volume, your
QPS, latency, all this stuff
automatically
for you and start throwing it on
to Prometheus and other
dashboards so you can start
running metrics and
understanding what is going on
in your services.
And I didn't have to write any
code for this.  Istio gives me
all these metrics out-of-the-box
for free.  And then finally, we
can use something
like zip kin or Yager, to do
tracing.  So our stack over
trace, a lot of these tools all
work.  So let's find some
traces.
So you can see here, we can see
our front end talks to our
middleware and talks to our back
end.  And the back end takes the
longest amount of time because
it's talking to our external
service, right?
But even more interesting than
this
, you can see here it actually
has back
end 2X and
back end 2X and middleware 2X.
I actually candy find one.
That's okay.
So you can see all the
distributed tracing and all I
had to do was forward
the trace headers along.
Those so as long as I'm
forwarding those
trace headers, I get distributed
tracing for free out-of-the-box.
And I have another talk talking
about open census which can
automatically forward these for
you as well.  So even less work
for you as a developer.  Okay.
Now let's do one final thing.
So here you can see when I hit
refresh, I'm always going to my
prod service.
But as a  tester, I kind of want
to use a canary service and see
what happens in this new path.
And the really nice thing is we
can do in production testing
using  Istio.  Because when we
have thousands of services it's
impossible to launch them all in
our local machine and test it
that way.  We want to push our
service like our -ue think it is
working so you push it into a
production cluster but we don't
want any production traffic
hitting it.
We just want test traffic
We will put up the last and
final route rule.
It is going to make a new route
called the middleware canary
route and it will
look for a header called, XDEV
user and whenever it sees the
value of super secret, it will
route it to our canary.  So all
normal traffic will go to our
production service and then the
super secret traffic will go to
our canary service.  Obviously
you do something like
authentication scheme not just
the word super secret, because
you know, security is important.
So let's take a look at that.
So let's deploy this rule.  And
so now if you go here, obviously
it will still go to our
production service but if we go
to postman, and
let's remove that fail header
and let's
go to XDEV user
super -- boom.  No.  Did I spell
it wrong?  Let's see what
happened.  What happened?
Disabled?  There we go.  Thank
you.
Middleware canary.
So we are able to route to a
specific service in the middle
of our stack using headers.
And that is because we are using
heder propagation.
Even if we had  friendy,000 --
2000 services, and you want to
make the
middle one, the  900th service a
special thing, by propagating
these headers, we
can actually use Istio and then
route to that one even if it's
in the middle of our stack.  So
not just a front end.  We can
test anything in the whole
stack using Istio and header
propagation.
Let's switch back to the slides,
please.
So we did all this stuff.  Thank
you all so much.  If you want to
get a deeper dive into
Istio, it's basically this topic
with more things focused
specifically on
Istio, check out my name.slash
Istio 101.  All this code is
open-source on my GitHub.
If you go to that website, Istio
101, I have a link there.
Check out Google Kubernetes code
and follow me on Twitter and if
you have any
questions, please follow me out
the door.  I'm going to go staff
the office hours right now so
come talk to me there.  Or talk
to me right outside.  Or find me
in the Sandbox.  I'm happy to
answer any questions.
I know we went quickly today.
And finally, if you have any
feedback, you know where to send
it.  5 stars only -- just
kidding.  I'll take anything.
But thank you so much and enjoy
the rest of your IO and the
concert tonight and I'll see you
out there.
[ Applause ]
Realtime captioning on this
screen.
>> How is everyone doing today?
My name is assurer sore I'm a
Product
Manager on the Hangouts Chat
bots framework.  I'm here about
Wesley, one of our G
Suite deputier advocates and
choo choo.  So today we are
going to talk about how you can
transform your workplace with
the Hangouts Chat bot framework.
And just a quick agenda, I'm
going to give background about
the new Hangouts Chat and the
bots user experience in
case you never tried the product
before and fass off to wes and
Juan to talk about the AP I and
show you a ton of
code samples and demos before I
wrap it up.
So quick show of hands, how many
people in the room use Hangouts
today and Gmail or on mobile?
Awesome.  So what you might not
know is that millions of
businesses use Hangouts
today for direct messaging or
light
weight group messaging with
their company.  And what we
heard from these companies is
that they are looking for more
persistent place for teams to
collaborate and communicate.
This past February we launched
the new Hangouts Chat T is
currently available for G Suite
customers at no additional
charge.
It's a brand new text stack with
Apps on Mac OS and windows,
Android, iOS and web.  It's
global out of the gate so it
works in 28 languages and is
accessible on all major screen
readers, on all major platforms.
And really the backbone of the
new Hangouts Chat are rooms, a
way to center the conversation
around a team, a project, an
event, basically anything you
want.  And it's obvious when
you're working on a project
you're going to be talking about
a bunch of different things.
I'm sure everyone in the room is
experienced this if you used
group messaging before.  You may
be talking about something
important, something at work,
about work, and then all of a
sudden, someone
in the message is like, hey,
guys, what do youment for lunch
today?  And then work keeps
going on and that's great but
then someone else who
is probably hungry says, I want
Mexican.  So, when this happens,
it's really hard to just figure
out what is happening and what
is the conversation we should be
focused on.
So conversations and rooms are
threaded
to prevent this exact problem.
Threading helps you separate the
every day chitchat from all of
the important stuff and not only
that, you can segment the
important stuff by different
threads to keep context around
those conversations.  If you use
Google groups for e-mail list or
identity management at your
company, you can add the Google
group to a room and anyone in
the room can also join the room.
Over time, these rooms will
contain all the things you
talked about, all the files you
shared so everything is ul iffy
indexed and searchable and you
can look for file type, keyword,
person,
look in one room, many rooms,
basically however you remember
what you're looking for.
Hangouts Chat has deep
integrations into G Suite so you
can pick any Docs or Drive file
from the picker and any time
you pace a Drive file or Docs
file, a link to it, we will
render a thumb nail and help you
grant access to everybody in the
room.  And if you find yourself
going back-and-forth too much
with someone or writing blocks
and blocks of text, we help you
with one click, up the bandwidth
of the conversation by creating
a video meeting with our sister
product, Hangouts meet.  So
again in the room can jump in
the meeting and you can resolve
what you wanted to resolve,
faster.
So you're no stranger to
conversational interfaces.  We
saw amazing things from the
assistant team yesterday at the
Keynote.  And bots at the
workplace, what they are meant
to do is help you blend
conversation and tools to
accelerate your work and reduce
all the context switching that
happens when you're working with
a bunch of different tools at
work.  You can talk to a bot
privately and a one-on-one
direct message or add a bot to a
room and then anyone in the room
can at mention it to do
something.
And while you can take anything
and make it a conversational
interface, you can take a
12-page form and make it a
conversational interface, we
think those interfaces shine for
three main use  cases at the
workplace.  One is a synchronous
notification.  So in this use
case, something happens
in a third party App and a
notification gets plummed into
the room where everyone can
start a conversation about it.
Another is one-off actions.  So
maybe you're talking about
someone, about what you need to
do, and then you say, hey
project management bot, create a
task about this item.  And it
does that.  And the third is
querying for information.  So
with this use case there is data
obviously in the third party
App, and you just want to find
it.  So you say project
management bot, what are Mandy
tiller's tasks it shows you what
the tasks are.
One of our big mantras on hang
out Chat team is bots are people
too.  They live alongside people
and there is no heavy
installation flow.  Nothing more
to learn.  If you know how to
start a direct
message with someone, add
someone to a
room, you know how to get
started with a bot.
Google launched a few bots of
their own, one is the meet bot
thatue uses natural language
processing and Machine Learning
to schedule meeting and book a
room for everybody in the room.
Another is the Google Drive bot
then nerves you when new files
are shared with you, new
comments are made or when people
request access toure yo files
and
not only can you see when people
request access but you can grant
access to the bot itself.  In
the two months since launching,
what we have seen is people
typically grant access to files
with the Google Drive bot eight
times faster than with e-mail.
So think about that.
You can speed up a common
workflow for
any App that you build by eight
times.
We have a number everthird party
bots like trella, to stay
informed about your
project's progress without
leaving the chatroom.  Ring
central to make video calls for
your team.  JIRA to get notified
about changes to issues, tasks,
and bugs and talk about the
changes as they happen; and we
are excited to aannounce that
box is launching a bot on
Hangouts Chat to help you find
recent fights or favorite files
to open or share without
switching context.
We have a number of bots in many
different business functions
like
developer tools, tasks, CRM, HR
support, and more.
Now I'm going pass this over
toess and
CHUAN JI:
Chuan Ji.
>> What we just saw are a bunch
of public bots written by
others.  And they are available
for everyone.  But what I want
you to think about is writing
bots on your own.  Whether it be
for your organization,
for your customers, or the
world.  Light a public bot like
the others you have seen.  Maybe
you're new to bots and you're
heditating going, how hard is
it?  But put simply, it's not
that bad.
Just think of bots as
microservices.  They are
simpler, there is less code
and you don't have to write a
complete web App or Mobile App.
You don't have that complexity.
So loss code means you can build
your Apps quicker but how quick?
The Motorola CIO got a domeo bot
up in less than an hour and
spent a bit more time to do one
for real work.  What does it do?
It talks to multiple  systems
and gathers customer order and
device warranty information to
present to perhaps the Customer
Service agent who needs
information when they are on a
call.
The main idea is that humans
used to
have to log into each of these
systems separately by hand, coal
8 all that information, before
they could tell their customer.
Now with a bot, you can
summarize all these results from
all of these different systems
together in a single
room so that all of the CSRs can
see it at the same time.
We are here to help get you
started.
All right, building quickly
isn't the only standout feature
of Hangouts Chat.  We want to
emphasize the platform has a lot
of flexibility.  There is many
different ways to implement and
host your bots.  So we are going
to go over some of the basics
and then walk you through each
option that you see here.  All
right.  So quick review.
Talking to APIs, and then
comparing that with bots.  So in
this diagram, we have an
application, we need reach an
API.  The data is protected and
so what typically has to happen
is the user has
to grant access to your
application through OAF, you
seen that dialogue window,
right?  Once that happens, the
App is able to reach the API,
access that user secured data on
their behalf, do all the work
that it needs to, and then
respond back to the user.
Right?  Everybody familiar with
this?  Great.
So with bots, it's a little bit
different.  It'saise three-tier
architecture here.  And what
happens is instead of a request
coming from an application,
requests really comes from a
user in a chatroom.  They enter,
I want to talk to this bot and I
will send it this payload so
that message gets entered into
Hangouts Chat and then Chat
contacts your bot.  Your bot
does all the work it needs to
do, collates the information,
and then returns that
information back to Hangouts
Chat which then rennedthers
result in the chatroom.
So it's a little bit different.
The key takeaway here is that
for your regular Apps, you call
APIs.
But with bots, Hangouts Chat
calls you.  So noodle on this
for a moment and once you get
this, then the implementation
path that you are going to take
is going to be more clear and
you can build your bots faster.
All right.
Now the most efficient bots are
return plain text because it is
short, it's fast, it gets the
job done.  But for a better user
experience, Hangouts chats
supports richer UIs called cards
that allow you to structure your
response data.
For example, if you look at the
cards sample here, you can see
that your bot could have
returned 5 lines of plain text
and done its job.  But this UI
card is more pleasing visually.
And in fact it can communicate
more than just plain text.  For
example, you can see that there
is a visual queue to show that
two of the 5
tasks have been completed from
this project management bot that
is managing like one of your
reports.
So that visual queue is really
helpful and if you you were to
do that in plain text, you have
to add extra symbols which may
get in the way of the data that
is coming back.  So cards are
great.
We'll look at them a little bit
more later.  Now if you already
have an App with
data that is kept secure behind
OFF you can expose your
functionality within Hangouts
Chat.
Our config flow lets your users
log do your App from Hangouts
Chat.  It's similar to this
example where you see the task
tracker bot which stores
information on Google sheet.
The sheet is protected data,
right?  So the user has to allow
your bot access to that
spreadsheet.
And then once the flow is
complete, users can access your
App and their
secured data directly from
Hangouts chatrooms and direct
messages.
Before showing you the code, I
want to give you a quick Ron
down of the event types that
hang out chats sends to your
bot.  Your bot can take action
when it is for example, added to
a space.
A great place to send a welcome
message.  Thank you for adding
me to this room.
She how to use me and also when
it is removed from a space, like
locking things or doing a
clean-up business lodging.  The
most common event type is
message, which is just when a
bot receives a normal message
entered by a user in a room or
DM and then the last one is card
click which is when a user
clicks on one of the UI card
elements we looked at earlier.
To keep things simple we will
focus on the latter pair.
Let's start with standard bots
that are running http.  As
mentioned before, the
development environment is quite
flexible.  Bots can be created
and  hosted on any platform.  In
other words, your language, your
stack, your Cloud, or ours.
Right?  So I presented at the
top here some Google Cloud
Platform or GCP products and
fire-based products you could
use but you don't have to.  So
Hangouts Chat also works with
bot-related environments like
Dialogflow and Hue bot.  Demo
some bots in some languages you
see here but it really doesn't
matter.  As long as the Hangouts
Chat service can http post to
your bot, that's all that is
really necessary.
All right.  You guys ready for
your hello world?  We will start
with the echo bot and happy to
pass it off to Juan, the
engineering lad for the Hangouts
Chat bot framework.
.
>> CHUAN JI: Cool. For shows
who haven't used Hangouts Chat
before, what you're seeing on my
screen is the macro OS desktop
for hang out Chat.
On the left is a list of rooms
and direct messages and on the
right is a message stream.  You
can see the group conversations
and so on.  Of course I can
create a new conversation here.
So, let's take a look at very
basic bot.  We'll call it the
echo bot which writes back
whatever the user sends to it.
So I'm going to talk to it here.
Hi.
And it will say, hi back to me.
So you saw the way I talked to a
bot is by mentioning it in a
message.  So in  rooms, only
messages that directly mention a
bot get sent to the
corresponding bot.  So the rest
of your conversation with your
team is private.  This is not
the only way to talk to a bot.
You can also have a direct
message, one-on-one direct
message with a bot.  Here you
can see I already have a direct
message with the echo bot as
well.  And here you can see I
don't have to mention the echo
bot at all.  Every message I say
in this direct message will be
sent to this bot because that is
the only other person in this
direct message.
Cool so now what we have seen
that you can interact with the
echo bot in Hangouts Chat, let's
take a look at how it is built.
Let's go back to the slid>>
WESLEY
CHAN: So here is the echo not
full glory in Python.
This uses the flask web
framework hostable on any Cloud
supporting Python web Apps.  As
you can see from the top of the
function, Hangouts Chat posts to
slash and then the code scans
the JSON payload for the message
type and then returns the same
message string along with the
user in the user name of
whomever called
the bot just like in the demo
you just saw.
Now Python isn't the only
choice.  Maybe you're using
Firebase F all your code is on
Firebase, you don't necessarily
want to host your bot on
something completely different,
right?  It's perfectly fine.
So here is the same bot in JS
and hosted by CloudFunctions for
Firebase.  If instead most of
your back end is on GCP, then
host it on the sister product,
Google Cloud functions and the
code will be nearly identical.
If you take a look at the code
here, it does pretty much the
same thing as all the littler.
It scans the I understand bound
message for message event and
then returns user name and
strings before and
it doesn't matter to Hangouts
Chat your code is in Java script
or Python and hosted on Firebase
or Google Cloud functions.
Remember, Hangouts Chat only
knows how to http post to your
bot.
So how are you doing so far?
Want to see more code?
Switching gears a little bit.
Let's talk a little bit about
Google Cloud Pub/Sub.  Many of
you know it's a realtime event
streaming and messaging system
where you
can have many producers and
reading and writing and probably
at different rates and all of
course could be coming from
different applications.  But,
what does this victim to do with
hang out Chat?  The platform is
supposed to be flexible.  What
if you decide to host your bot
on premise and behind a
firewall?  In this case,
Hangouts Chat cannot contact
your bot so what can you do?
This is the perfect use case for
Pub/Sub.  Hangouts Chat sends a
message to
Pub/Sub instead of your bolt
because it can't reach it.  It
has to register to allow the bot
to get the messages from Pub/Sub
and bring it through the
firewall and then your
on-premise bot can service the
request,
do all the calls it needs to do
and gathers the information and
responds to Lang outs Chat like
normal.  Let's see how to use
it.
The next example is the Java
version of the echo bot.  A lot
of Enterprises uses Java and so
we want to show an example here
as well.  So Python and Node,
you can see the
cold handles the event and scans
for message type and then
replies with a
message text and user name it's
like the other but more verbose.
What if this bot is in our
corporate data center behind the
firewall?
We just meaned that puck sub is
the right solution --  mentioned
- audio how doe we tweak to work
with Pub/Sub?  It's not too bad.
If you look over here, you can
see the extra code that we added
to our Java echo bot that uses
object mapper to
convert between JSON and Java
objects and get the message from
Pub/Sub and convert to JSON for
processing.
It passes that event object to
the handle math we saw in the
privacy slide which handles a
message as iftives sent
via http frost Hangouts Chat T
doesn't know the difference.
That's awesome!
So we discussed hosting on
Google's Cloud, your Cloud, with
or without a firewall.  Let's
bring it back inside Google with
a little twist called Google App
script.  First things first.
Quick quiz.  How many feel it's
important to have
off to help keep your data user
data secure?
How many of you like writing
authcode?  Chirp chirp.  That's
what I thought.  What about
managing your own servers or VMs
on premise or in the Cloud?  Not
easy eater.  So in that case,
App script is for you.  Have you
heard of App script before?
How many have heard of App
script before?  Not enough.
It's like another Google secret
but just not a good one because
we launched it almost a decade
ago.  So what is it?
It's a customized Java script
environment where we take care
of the servers and auth, and you
have access to more than 40 G
Suite and Google APIs with just
function calls.  Now if you try
to build a bot with it, we
provide you a one-click bot
template so you're already given
a basic working bot to hack on
right away.  Check out the video
if you want to learn more about
the secret.
So App script is a serverless
environment for all developers,
including all you product folk,
business analyst and data
scientists out there.
Now here is the at echo bot in
App script.  Now let's pause for
a minute here.  Really look that
the code while it is
identical in functionality as
the others, it's only one line
of code!  And not only that,
it's the easiest way to deploy a
bot within your organization.
So the echo part is a good start
but can
you show us more useful App
script bot?
?
>> So we will show you a quick
bot, and we will do a little
twist and translate it.
So let's switch to demo.  I have
called the translate bot and
I'm going to say, welcome to
Google I/O in English.
And it's giving us back the same
message but in Japanese.  Cool!
Let's take a look at how that is
built.
Let's go back to the slides,
please.
Here it is.  Notice how it is
almost as simple as the echo
bot, the only difference is that
we are now calling the Google
translate API and how do we call
the Google translate AP!
It's a function call away.
You're not importing SDK or
downloading anything.  It's just
there.  And you can see how it
is very intuitive to use.  You
pass the message to user sent,
in this case it is E.message to
argument text.  Argument text
being the text you just sent
without the bot's own name in it
and pass the source language and
the target language.  And then
you return the result Aztecs.
That's it.  It's almost too
simple, right?
Let's take a look at a more
advanced example.
So let's cut to the demo again.
Thank you.
So in preparation for this talk,
our
team has been using a Google
spreadsheets to track all work.
Each of us has a task assigned
and I built a simple bot to take
a look at where everyone is at
in terms of tasks.  So, I call
it the task tracker bot.
So I'm going to call it here.
So looks like we have a bunch of
tasks pending here.  So let's
take a look at the spreadsheet.
Can you see the spreadsheet?
So, you can see this is a plain
Google spreadsheet.  The first
row with the column names and a
bunch of tasks here assigning
and status.
The bot is really pulling the
data from the spreadsheet
showing tasks not yet completed.
So I'm going to mark all of
these completed right now since
we are all
already standing on the IO
stage.  I'm going to mark
everything completed
and then go back to the Chat App
and I'm going to query it again
through my task tracker bot.
And this time it will tell us
that
there are no more tasks T.
>> Video is coming soon, by the
way.
>> Cool.
Let's go to the slides.
So this is the code.
This is the code for the task
tracker bot.  And you can see it
fits on one slide.  So it's
really not that complicated.
You can see we are doing some
processing here where we are
opening up
the spreadsheet opening by  ID,
grabbing the data from the
spreadsheet in a two dimensional
array and doing a little bit of
processing here, removing the
first
row, which is just the column
names, filling out the rows that
are already completed, mapping
each row into a string, putting
them together into a message and
then  returning them to hang out
Chat.
>> I don't see any author API
calls here.
>> That's a very good question,
wes.
>> So, notice how -- in terms of
API calls like the translate
bot, all the  API calls are just
function calls.
It's just especially to open ID,
spreadsheet get data range, get
values, get URL.  That's it.
You're not like doing
complicated -- not building
requests or using SDK.  You just
call them as if they were built
in.  And in addition, you don't
have to write about explicit
authentification code.
So obviously this spreadsheet is
not publicly visible but because
I used this bot before, I have
given access to it and Google
App script is responsible for
handling all of that.  You don't
have to write a call back.  You
don't have to store the
authtokens.  You don't have to
refresh them.  It's taken care
of by App script.  So after the
user logs into for the first
time, App script will take care
of it.
So so far, the bots you have
seen
collect data and return them in
plain text but let's take a look
at how to present a richer UI in
the form of  cards.
>> WESLEY CHAN: It's true that
plain text is the easiest and
fastest but for the cards, you
have to use cards to make your
response look good.  So that is
what this is for.  So, you can
use JSON mark up to construct
the UI card and then the best
part is it is wants to run
anywhere.  You don't need to
write a separate mobile version
of your bot.  Cards can be
interactive like the poll you
see here.
Users interact by  clicking on
the vote button and they are
updatable.  The bar chart and
the votes update.  Now the user
experience will be much worse if
a new card was generated for
every vote, right?
The bot framework supports a
variety of widgets.  So here are
a couple to get an idea like
buttons, formatted temperatures,
structured data, images, links
and more.  But really the
widgets are just building
blocks.  The real magic is when
you put them all together and
assemble them into cards whether
interactive, updating or both.
So let's see a demo of a bot
that has
interactive and updating cards.
>> CHUAN JI: Great. Thank you.
So it's a great day here today
at the amphitheater.
How many of you have been to
this amphitheater before?  Some
of you.  Okay.  So that's more
than I expected, actually.
But for the rest of you, I just
wrote
a little bot that helps us find
the amphitheater on Google Maps.
So I call it the where is, bot.
So where is shoreline
amphitheater?
And what this bot does is pull
up a
map of the amphitheater and it
shows an
image of the map.
>> WESLEY CHAN: I don't see an
amphitheater there.
>> CHUAN JI: On the bottom you
see a row
of buttons and guess what
happens?
>> WESLEY CHAN: I don't see it,
still.  There it is.
>> CHUAN JI: So it zooms in here
and the minus button zooms out.
So we can see the Bay Area and
all of its glory.
>> WESLEY CHAN: What is that
Google Maps icon down there?
>> CHUAN JI: When you click on
this
button, it will take you to the
Google
Maps site centered on the
location I typed and on mobile,
it will take you to the Google
Maps App.  Cool.
Would you like to see how this
is built?  Let's go back to the
slides.
Cool.  So here is the first to
start with our familiar on
message function.  So as you
already know, the on message
function is invoked when the
user sends a message to the bot
n this case, I  said, where is
the shoreline amphitheater?
So Java's return the card but in
this case, we are going to move
the logic for constructing the
card into a new function we will
show called, build message.
Note here that build message
takes in three arguments.
It takes in the location the
user typed.  This is argument
text.  So we move the space and
it will take initial zoom level
and it will take in a third
parameter, the responsive to.
So when a new message is sent,
we want
to send a new message always, so
we use the new message type.
We'll take a look at that
litter.  So now let's look at
build message.  This is the meat
of the code.  You saw before it
takes in location,
the user typed and zoom level
and takes in the response type.
So what we are going to do in
build message is we are going to
construct each element or each
widget inside this card in
sequence.  So we start with the
header.  You can see just like
the header, the other widgets
are the same.  All of these
widgets are represented by a
plain Java script object and the
header has two minutes.
The title and icon.
So next, we are going to build
the image that we see here, the
map image.  We'll take a look at
how that is built in the next
slide and then construct a row
of buttons like you see on the
bottom.
We will create two more
functions, build Google Maps
link which takes in location and
we'll build or have a function
called, build button, which
takes in the label, the location
and the target zoom level the
user will be taken to when they
click the button.
So finally we will put it all
together into one big JSON
object.  And return this object
back to Hangouts Chat and that
creates the card.
So let's look at each of these
widgets.  So first let's look at
build image.
It shows a widget from Google
Maps in an image widget.  So in
this example we will use the
Google Maps API which is built
into App script.
Just say maps new static map.
We set a bunch of new
parameters, like location zoom
level, a marker, the red
pin you see there, and we can
just grab a mat URL.  Pretty
simple.  It's just a function
call away.  And then finally we
will take the URL
and construct a Java script
object that represents the image
widget and return it.
So next we'll build zoom
buttons.  These are interactive.
So in addition to creating the
UI side
of things, we will add a text
button which contains text label
and we will have an unclicked
parameter.
What is inside the unclicked
parameter?
It's going to be the payload we
want sent back to our bot when a
user
interacts with one of these
buttons.  So in here we'll set
two parameters.  The location
the user tied in the beginning
and the new zoom level the user
will be taken to when they click
the button.
So, like I said, this object
payload will be sent back to our
bot when the user clicks this
button.
So where do we receive this
payload?
We receive a function called on
card click.  So just like on
message which is triggered when
a user sends a message.  On card
click is triggered when a user
clicks on a button in a card.
What it receives is the payload
of the button that the user
clicked so we can extract the
parameters that were
assigned to the button and see
thics attracted location and
zoom level and we do a bit of
math to make sure the zoom level
isn't out-of-bounds and then we
just call the same build message
function that constructed the
initial card.  The only
difference is that in this time
we will set the parameter to
update message because we want
to not post a new message.  We
want to update the original card
the user clicked on.
So finally, we have the icon on
the bottom left that takes the
user to Google Maps.  So like
the zoom buttons, it will have
or create a button but it's not
going to have an unclick handler
payload that will be returned to
the bot because we don't want
the bot to be invoked, we just
want to send the user to Google
Maps.  Here we construct a link
to Google Maps and then attach
it to the open link
property which just instructs
Hangouts chats to not deliver
the response back to the bots,
but just call-up Google Maps.
So I want to stress through all
these examples it shows you how
to build this interactivity in
App script.
This functionality is not
limited to App script.  The same
functionalities are available
as well if you build your bot in
using HTP endpoint or Pub/Sub
endpoint.  It means you can
build the same rich
user experience with cards in a
language of your house and
deploy to the environment of
your choice.  Cool.
So so far we have shown you bots
that respond to something user
does.  User has to send a
message or click on a button for
your bots to do anything.  But
what if the bot needs to notify
the user about something?
>> WESLEY CHAN: So thank you.
So the framework supports
asingeinous messages perfect for
long-running jobs.
A synchronous message can be
sent to specific threads for
context.  So here our bot needs
to contact Hangouts Chat.  So
when you see auth, it's a strong
indication you're using API.  A
bot has to call into Hangouts
Chat now.
So this Python sample uses the
bot's
permission Scopelus service
another credentials you got
downloaded from your project and
then establish a service
endpoint to the API like with a
discovery.build call and then
you can use the A approximate.
I to send message to a DM or
room.
Now like any other bot, this bot
can
call other APIs or do any other
processing you want done and
then collate the information and
send it back
into the room with the DM.
More generally, besides just
creating messages, the API can
do all operations on messages.
It also has the additional fee
towers
give you more context like
getting information on rooms or
members who are in rooms and
DMs.  And in addition to the
API, Hangouts Chat supports
in-coming web hosts great for
one off alerts like when a
server goes down.  They are
quick and dirty or easy and you
can integrate with any of your
custom workflows and the way you
do it is go to the room with the
DM and pull down configure web
hooks and then from there, you
can see the current web hooks
that are currently defined.  And
you can have different ones
because you may have different
Apps that are posting different
alerts.  So just click on the
icon to the right
to copy the web hook URL to use.
Now in coming web hooks can come
from monitoring Apps or the
command line.  So we will prove
this by doing an
incoming web hook from a curl
command.
>> CHUAN JI: Thank you. So as
wes showed you the way you
configure a web hook is get to a
room and click on config web
hooks and we will see a dialogue
that shows you what you have
conphysician.  There will be a
URL here that you can use.
So in this case, let's say we
have imaginary task manager App
and it just wants to send a
quick notification into hang
outs Chat when something
happens.
So I want to switch to terminal
here and here you can see I
pasted the
command and it's going to be a
command sending http post
request T will contain
a JSON payload and it will
contain the URL I copied from
the dialogue from in Hangouts
Chat in the background.
And the text I'm going to send,
remember this is the same
payload, same JSON
object you would send from App
script or from requests, it's
the same format.  So just send
this to payload and let me hit
enter here.  And everything goes
well -- you can see before we
close the terminal, you can see
I have gotten back response a
JSON formatted payload from
Hangouts
Chat that shows me the ID of the
message that was just created,
the space that it was posted in
and so on.
Now let's take a look at this
message in Hangouts Chat.  You
can see here this created a new
conversation.  And it contains
the text that we were just sent
to it.
Let's go back to the slides.
So one of the most innovative
featureses in Hangouts Chat as
Mike
explained earlier,
conversations.  So threaded
conversations are great
for grouping relevant context
together so in the context of
imaginary task manager App, what
we really like to see is the
history around the particular
task  grouped together like the
top thread you can see here.  So
what this means is that all the
relevant discussions from
people, all the relevant
notifications from this App, get
grouped into the same
conversation.  This is very easy
for people to understand what is
going on.
So how do we do this?
Just like you saw on my screen,
after you send the request to
Hangouts Chat,
we returned the data, the IDs
and so on about the message
created.  So remember that and
remember the association between
task ID and the thread ID and
that is perfectly fine.  Nothing
wrong with that and you dock
that.  But since this is a
really common use case, we
thought we could make it more
convenient.
So, once one solution we came up
with is the idea of a thread
key.  So think of thread key as
a custom identifier.  It is some
identifier that makes sense to
you in your problem domain.  So
for example, in our task manager
App it could be a task ID, if
you have a customer ticket
tracking system, it could be a
ticket ID, maybe a customer
order ID.  Doesn't matter.  What
you do with it is specify in
each request that you make when
you create a message in Hangouts
Chat.  And we dot heavy
lifting.  Remember, the first
time we see a message that has a
particular thread key, we'll
create a new conversation, some
sequence messages get post thed
into same conversation.  Now you
don't have to remember that
mapping between an entity in
your problem domain and a thread
or conversation in Hangouts
Chat.
So of course this example here
on the
slide shows you a command very
simple
but this of course doesn't just
look for incoming web hooks or
curl T works for
bots as well so you could write
as a  bot, and could use thread
key to do the same group
conversation -- group message
into the same conversation.
All right.  So this wraps up our
introductory tour of the
Hangouts Chat bot framework.
I'll hand it off to Mike to take
us across the finish line.
>> MIKE SORVILLO: Thank you wes
and Juan.  Just to summarize
what we talked about today.
The Hangouts Chat service with
bots helps teams accelerate team
work and productivity.  You can
stay notified, automate tasks,
query information, all without
changing anything context.  And
like they showed you, there is
many different ways to connect.
You can spent up your own web
service using any Cloud or
language, use Cloud
Pub/Sub to with a firewall in
addition your organization or
the  easiest way to streamline a
workflow is using App script
where you don't have to worry
about servers, auth, or anything
like that.
So to get started, check out our
website for more documentation
on how to do all of this.
If you're a G Suite customer and
you
haven't tried Hangouts Chat
today, try the product itself.
And if you have more questions,
we are happy to answer them in
dome B.  We will be giving more
are domeos and could show you
more details on how to publish
bots and what not.
So, before we all leave, we want
to hear from you.  So please
provide feedback for this
session at google.
com/io/schedule.  And thank you
for all coming.  Enjoy the rest
of the conference.
[ Applause ]
By now you checked into
registration to receive your
badge. It must be visibly warn
at all times and you'll need it
to enter the after hours
activities at the end of days 1
and 2. Throughout the event,
make sure to visit google.
com/io, or download the IO
Mobile App for the most
up-to-date schedules and
conference map.
For questions or assistance,
stop by the information desk
located across from the CodeLabs
building or chat with a staff
member wearing a yellow badge.
Sessions will take place in the
Amphitheater and at the 8 stages
throughout the venue. If you
haven't already, reserve a seat
on the website or Mobile App.
If you miss a session, don't
worry, recordings will be
available on line shortly after
they end. Be sure to visit the
CodeLabs building for hands on
experience with ready-to-code
kiosks and self-paced tutorials.
Google staff will be on hand for
helpful advice and to provide
direction if you need support.
Make some time to visit the
office hours and App Reviews
tent to meet one-on-one with
Googlers, ask all your technical
questions and get feedback on
your projects.  If you're
looking to network with Googlers
and fellow developers, join one
of the several meet-ups hosted
in the Community Lounge.
Finally, we'd like to visit you
to visit the Sandbox Domes,
where you can explore, learn and
play with our latest
products and platforms and
interact with demos and physical
installations and more. After
sessions are done for the day,
stick around for food, drinks
and music and fun and be
prepared for surprises along the
way. We would like to take this
opportunity to remind you we are
dedicated to providing an
inclusive event experience for
everyone.
And by attending Google I/O, you
agree to our Code of Conduct
posted throughout the venue.
Your opinion is valuable to us.
After the event, look on the fur
feedback form to share your
experience.
experience.Thanks for attending
and have a
wonderful time exploring Google
I/O.
ANNOUNCER: At this time, please
find your seat.
Our session will begin soon.
Is
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, everybody. Good
morning.  And welcome.  We are
so kited to have you huer.  My
name is alley, I work on
Firebase and I'm Product Manager
on performance monitoring.
>> Hello, everyone. I'm Jason a
Project Manager on Firebase and
work on crash littics.
>> I'm an engineering manager on
Firebase and I work on crash
littics.  Thank you very much
for coming today.  We are really
Excited to talk to you about how
to improve your App's quality
and stability using Firebase
tools.  But we want to start at
the beginning.  So you have got
a great idea and you start to
code it up.
You're spending a lot of time
making sure that your App is
working, you're debugging,
showing your friends, and it's
really exciting part of the
journey.
But how many people here have
experienced user's churning
because of a bad experience once
an App shifts to the App Store.
It's happened to me too.  And
it's really frustrating.  And
our metrics show that it's a big
problem.
42% of one-star reviews in the
App Store specifically mention
stability and bugs.  This means
that users are taking notice
when these problems exist in our
Apps and they are making note of
them in the App Store, which is
going to make it
harder for you to get and grow
new  users.
Not only that, but 62% of users
uninstall an App after ad about
experience like this.  And in
many of those cases, that is
after a first-time bad
experience.  So you can imagine
this makes a huge difference in
your ability to make your App a
business.
On the flip side, 73% of 5-star
reviews in the App Store
actually mention speed, design
and usability.
So users really appreciate when
this is delightful in an App and
they call it out.  That's really
exciting.
And when it comes to App
quality, the first step is
making sure that your App is
throughly tested before you ever
release to the App Store.
And Firebase test lab is your
best friend when it comes to
that.
As we announced yesterday,
Firebase test lab is now
available across platform on iOS
and Android which is super
exciting.  And we really rely on
it heavily.
We know testing is important but
it can be really hard.  And it
doesn't have to be.
Because test lab does all the
heavy lifting for you.
With over 1000 devices ranging
in
different device models, screen
sizes, OSs, it's able to cover
all of the different use cases
so you don't need to worry about
it.  And there is the new
accessibility report so it's not
just testing whether or not your
App is stable or crashing, it's
actually helping you understand
if it's useable, which is super
cool.  And it's really easy to
get started.
All you have to do is drag and
drop your App binary and you're
able to get out-of-the-box test
right away without having to
right any code and it will help
you understand your performance,
start up time, as well as
crashes and a lot more.
So you're able to be confident
in your App's performance before
you ever ship to the App Store.
But we know it's only the
beginning of the story, right?
Because it's pretty hard to
catch everything before it goes
out to users.
And we feel proud that users
have trusted crash littics for
more than six years as your
partner in understanding how
stable your App is.
Crash lit 6 run -- generally
available in fair base, which is
really exciting.  It's our new
home and really looking forward
to having closer ties with the
other Firebase tools available
to make it the best possible
experience for users.
Crash littics is running on over
3 billion devices worldwide.
And that is pretty amazing
because it means we are seeing a
huge range of crash data across
the world.  But what does it
mean in terms of the data that
we are  processing?  Let's take
a look.
We process about 1.
5 million events every second.
That's about two billion events
per day.  What does it look like
in terms of users actually using
an App that is crashing?  So
imagine we are all here in sunny
California and your phone
crashes seven times while
walking around the conference.
That would be pretty
frustrating.  There is a very
good chance you're going to
uninstall that App and there is
a pretty good chance you're
going to tell all your friends
auto terrible and not to use it.
Now imagine every person in the
United States had a mobile phone
and it crashed seven times
today.  That is equivalent to
the amount of
data we are processing in our
system every single day.
It is a lot of data and it is
really hard to understand what
you need to pay attention to.
Not only that, but when you get
a crash from the device, it
looks like this.  It's pretty
hard to understand, right?
Maybe if you look really
closely, you'll see some things
that highlight your App but it's
hard to figure out where to get
started.  So crash littics takes
all that data and all this
information from the device and
we put it into a beautiful
dashboard that makes it easy for
you to understand what you need
to focus on first.
We have our crash-free user
statistic at the top which is
the industry standard to
understand how your App is
doing.
We also have your session list,
issue
list, which allows you to see
right away what needs your
attention T shows you cigarette
butts of information like if a
certain OS is seeing this issue
more than others.  If there is
specific device that is have
this problem, and so you're able
to
know right off the bat what
needs your attention.
When you dig in further, you're
able to see how this issue is
trending across different
versions as well as the blame
frame where we think you should
really start your debugging
process.
It allows you to go confidently
into triaging of an issue so
you're able to solve it quickly
and get your users on to a
better path fast.  But we know
you can't always be at your
computer it's not really
possible.  So we have got your
back no matter where you are
with realtime e-mails that let
you know if there is a stability
issue with new issue, regressed
issue or velocity alerts.  No
matter where you are, we have
got your back.
Now I'm going to pass it over to
alley, who is obsessed with
performance on our team.
>> Alley: Yes in, deed. Thank
you.
So as you heard, clearly App's
ability plays a huge role in how
your users perceive your App.
Unfortunately, though, it
doesn't just stop there.  Users
are also known to have a very
short attention span.
They expect a highly performance
and smooth  experience.  And for
this exact reason we went to
work last year to build Firebase
performance monitoring which we
announced this time at IO last
year on
the same stage T supports IO.
And androids and allows you to
report a lot of data about how
your App performance from the
point of view of your users.
Now if you use performance
monitoring before, you probably
know that in addition to being
able to instrument things that
are accustomed to your App, you
also get a lot of data
out-of-the-box just by
installing the  SDK.  You will
get things like the network
activity between your App and
the back end user.  So it will
report things like how often
your endpoints fail or what
response latency your users are
experiencing and we do that for
any backends whether third party
SDKs you have in your App or
your own managed services.
We also report App start
duration, a key metric because
it ties into that first
impressions that your users get.
And as of yesterday we started
reporting rendering data.
Now we tell you how often your
App drops a frame and where this
happens.  Now this is pretty
important for any developer but
if you're a play developer
it's especially important F have
an App on the play store you
probably know that last year the
play developer console
introduced this new section
called, Android vitals.  And
what it does is report a number
of metrics that are key to your
success.  Naturally some of
these metrics are performance
metrics.  You see an example
right here in this case slow
rendering and a similar metric
called frozen frame and they are
both about how smoothly your
animations and App in general
renders.
No you for these let metrics we
heard feedback from our
developers.  People love to have
this data but they don't know
how to act on it and where
exactly in the App this happens.
And that is exactly where
Firebase performance comes in.
Because not only do we now
report these metrics
out-of-the-box, but we also do
it per screen.
So if your Android, we'll show
you the number of frozen frames
or slow frames per Android
activity and also  for iOS, we
do the same thing, we show you
these numbers for controllers.
So you get a lot of extra
context this way to help you get
started on fixing the shall.
We'll see an example of how this
works in a second but first, I
want to talk a little bit about
the reception that we seen with
Firebase performance.
The last time we talked about
this was back in October at the
Firebase summit in Amsterdam and
we were super Excited to tell
you we were processing as many
as 30 billion performance events
per day.  And since then, only
six months later, this number
has grown to 100 billion events
per day.  So we couldn't be more
excited about the trajectory we
are seeing and about the quality
of the feedback and the
reception that our developers
has given to us.
So please keep it coming T will
only help us make the product
better.
Now, as you can imagine, this is
a lot of data to go through.
And if you're a developer that
is looking to improve your App,
this can be
a little bit of intimidating, a
lo the ever data to assist
through through and because of
that, our console is now getting
better.  We now have a new
feature called, the issue feeds,
which helps you identify
the top performance issues you
have and appears right at the
top of the main page in the
performance console.  So we'll
tell you things like, how often
your endpoints fail or if your
App start is slow so that you
can spend much less time sifting
through that data and
more time acting on it and
fixing issues.
And finally, if you're around
for the Firebase session
yesterday, you heard that
Firebase performance is now
generally available.  We have
data as of yesterday and we are
really Excited about how battle
tested our SDKs are on iOS and
Android about the overall value
our developers have found with
performance monitoring.  So if
you haven't tried it so far, now
would be a great time to do so.
All right, so let's get to the
fun part.
I'm going to invite alley back
on
stage so she can tell us how she
got to use these products in
building one of our own Apps.
>> Thank you. So you just heard
a good overview of these
different products but we really
wanted to talk about how this
actually looks in an App and how
it works with the timeline as
you build and release your
application.
We are going to specifically
focus on
the Firebase App quality tools
but it's worth noting that
friendly picks uses a lot of
other Firebase tools like
functions, databases, storage
and auth.  So it is has a lot of
good innocence there and you can
check out the code for yourself.
Friendly picks allows you to
take a photo and upload it and
share it with your friends.
Here is jays son taking a
picture of his dog Percy, which
he does a lot and putting a
caption with it and sharing it.
It's pretty simple.  And our
first step was making sure that
it was well tested.
We partnered and used test lab
heavily to make sure this worked
well and we could ship
confidently.  And when we looked
at our dashboard, we noticed
that there was a problem right
away.  We saw that a test was
failing.  And this was pretty
surprising to us because we had
all been playing with the App
and we hasn't seen anything
problems.
We were able to go to the
video's tab and see a simulation
of this crash actually happening
on a device which was super
helpful in debugging the
problem.
You can see here that we are
uploading a photo.  Okay and
it's freezing and then it
crashings.  So that was really
important to catch early and
make sure that we had a good
experience for users.  This
allowed us to ship to the App
Store with confidence because we
knew we were going to have a
good experience for our users.
Now I'll pass it off to JASN who
is keeping an eye on stability
for friendly picks.Ed.
>> JASN: So I want to walk you
through real scenario that
happened shortly after we
shipped friendly picks.  So I
went in to upload a photo, most
likely of Percy which I'm super
excited you got to see a picture
of, and the App crashed for me
and it crashed  immediately on
launching it.
Which was surprising because as
we discussed we tested it
manually and ran it through test
lab and things were smooth and
we hadn't shipped any recent
changes.  So I immediately log
in and go to crash  littics and
notice a huge drop in crash free
users.  Clearly not just me
experiencings this issue cra.
And it's attributed to one
spectacular issue.  So I dive in
to see what is going on.  I can
see a big spike with this issue
and I look at what is going on.
Something to do with MD user
dictionary.  I talked to other
folks to see what is going on
and what we realized is the web
team shipped a change that was
allowing users to upload a photo
without a user name.  They
weren't sitting it to null.
And our iOS client was expecting
null in those scenarios.
So it was causing a crash.  It
was crashing immediately on
launch because the first post
trying to load.
So pretty simple fix.
We made the iOS map more
resilient do non-null and
shipped the change to make sure
the web client was setting those
scenarios to null, and we
documented what happened.  So
crash littics has a great future
called, notes.  In notes, I can
document exactly what I just
walked through to tell other
members of our team what was
going on, how we fixed it, why
we fixed it and this is really
great to make sure you don't
sort of relive some of the same
mistakes if you use a bug
tracking system, you can put a
ticket in there.  You see we
captured the bug, put it  away.
Hopefully it doesn't regress and
escape.  We are all set up for
now.
The next thing I did is make
sure that change actually was
fixed.  So you can see here that
I'm pinning one.1 the recent
version that we just shipped to
the App Store and pin builds is
a really great feature in crash
littics because if you're one of
those development teams that is
always turning out QA builds or
Beta builds or local builds, you
may have a long list of versions
and by  pinning the most
relevant ones to the top you can
get access to the ones that are
in the App Store so it's easy to
keep those top of mind.
So I filtered on to that and
noticed that there are still a
few issues I needed to deal with
but luckily that prevalent one
we just fix said no longer
there.  So, what I want to make
sure here, what I wanted to make
sure is that that never happened
again where I was the one that
tested and found out what was
going on or maybe someone on my
team.  I wanted to know about it
right away.  And maybe I wasn't
paying attention to the e-mails
that tally was mentioning.  But
I do spend a lot of time in
slack.
So maybe as you heard yesterday
in the what's new in Firebase
talk, in the integrations tab,
we now have the ability to
config slack.  We wanted to take
advantage of this.  So super
easy.  Just need to copy and
paste your slack web hook URL
and set the channel you want the
notifications to go to.  So in
our case it's the friendly picks
iOS room where my team is monare
toking
this and I want new issues,
regressed issues and velocity
alerts.
And velocity alert is when one
issue is causing a significant
portion of all your issues to
crash.  That's something you
want to pay attention to.
This issue would have triggered
a velon the U.S. alert.  So
hopefully I don't get one of
those in the future but at least
it will come through in slack
where I'm paying attention to.
Ment I'm going to turn it over
to alley who will tell us what
is going on with performance
while  debugging this.
>> Alley: Cool. So I'm curious
myself how performance is going.
So, we'll stay in the Firebase
console but switch over to the
performance page.  And we land
there.  When we land there, the
first thing I see are the
dashboard tab and the number of
high-level metrics about how my
App is performing.  So I see
things like the duration of
different parts of the App,
network success rate over the
last 30 days,
network response latency by
country ask so on.  What I'm
curious about is how friendly
picks is performing on the
device.
So I'm going to go ahead and
click on that tab and when I do
that, I see a couple of
sections.  The first one
duration, tells me things like
how long App start is taking in
this case it is 2.4 seconds and
it sounds about reasonable.  The
second section I see here is the
rendering data.  This is the new
feature I was talking about.
And if you look at it, you can
see there is a couple of metrics
being reported here.  Slow
frames and frozen frames.  Slow
frames are basically any frames
that take more than 16
milliseconds to render and
therefore deviate from that
ideal 60 frames per second
standard that we always want to
have in our animations.
Frozen frames on the other hand
are frames that take more than
milliseconds and therefore
create this noticeable freeze
that interrupts the user flow.
For each one of these two
metrics, we report the values
per  screen.  So since we are
dealing with iOS App in this
case, we see it per the
controller.
If you look closely, you can see
that the animation view
controller specifically has a
higher percentage of slow frames
compared to other screens.  So
this is obviously not a great
thing and I want to look into a
bit more.
So I'm going to click on it and
I land
on this details page that
details out the characteristics
of slow frame rendering for that
screen.  And I can see that the
breakdown of versions that I
have, this part I see at the top
left of the page, shows me that
there is no significant
difference between the last few
versions.  So this is not
necessarily regression
that got introduced because of
my --
If I scroll down, I can see a
breakdown of the percentage of
slow frames by a number of
attributes.  By things like
which devices the users were on,
which App versions they were
using, and which countries they
were based in.  And specifically
for device, I can see
a couple of warnings on the
iphone 5 and the I pad air and
they tell me that these two
devices specifically have a much
higher percentage of slow frames
compared to other devices.  Now
this makes sense.  These are
older devices and I would expect
their rendering is not going to
be as smooth as some of the
newer ones but the cool thing
here is using this data, I can
specifically target these
devices and give them a
different treatment so for
instance, I can show less
animations or no  animations for
these users so they can have an
overall better experience.  And
just like that, we found our
first
insight using the console data
and we dealt with it by having a
targeted experience.
Cool?
A.So I'm going to ship this fix
and now we can see our App is
growing.  It's expanding to new
users and markets.  We are
getting a lot of reviews coming
in.  A lot are good reviews,
which is a great thing.  I want
to jump back into the
performance console and see how
things are.  And when I do that,
I notice that there is an issue
now that popped up that I did
not have before.  And this issue
tells me my image service has
been taking longer to respond in
the last few  days.
If I click on it, I can see a
detailed overtime chart that
shows that over the last seven
days or so, there has been a
significant  percentage of
samples that have  exceeded the
network threshold we  have,
which is two seconds.  This is
the default network threshold we
have.  You can tweak this if it
doesn't make sense for your
specific use case.  In here we
will stick with the default
threshold and try to examine why
this is happening.
Now if I scroll down, and look
at my breakdowns, I can see that
users in India have been
specifically  experiencing
higher network latency compared
to other users.  Now, I have a
theory on why this might be
happening.
I think this is happening
because this is an service that
we have not been
using image compression so far
and users with typically slower
data connections will have a
harder time fetching these
images.  How do a make sure my
hypothesis is correct?  The
answer obviously is an
experiment.
So I'm going to jump back into
my code
and create a custom trace and
have it
trap the logic I used to fetch
these images and for that trace,
called image fetch, I'm going to
set a custom attribute, call it
compression, and turn
it on and off depending on which
variant.  Experiment you're in.
Now I'm going to ship this code
and a couple of days later I'll
jump back into the console and
check out the details I have for
image fetch trace I just
created.  And I can see that in
addition to the traditional
breakdowns I have, I also
now have a compression, this
custom attribute, and I can see
the difference in performance
specifically in network latency
is huge between the cases where
compression is on and
compression is  off.
So now I have the data that I
need to make sure that
compression is the right fix.
And I can go ahead and role it
out to every user.  So the cool
thing here is that not only did
we find out about an issue using
our console when we didn't know
it existed, but we also used the
console to monitor the effects
of the fix and make
sure that it had the intended
effects.
But now, it looks like we have a
new slack notification that is
complaining about a new fatal
crash.
So I'm going to let yea son take
a look at this.
>> JASN: So, it's a bummer we
got a crash but great that I
immediately knew about this.
So, clicking through from slack,
takes me directly into the issue
details page.  So, I noticed a
few things immediately about
this issue that are a little bit
unique.  One is that it's not in
my main App code.  The problem
is actually in a system library,
photo library severances.  And
the second thing is that there
is a bit of data at the top and
this is what we call a crash
insight and a crash insight is
actually a solution to what is
going on here.
So as tally mentioned earlier,
we get billions of crashes a
day.
As you can imagine, not every
one is unique to each
application.  Many of those
crashes are common across
thousands of applications.
Typically those common crashes
are
either programming errors or
issues in third party libraries
or issues in the system
framework.  And in our case,
what we are doing wrong is, we
are trying to access the
camera role to upload a photo
before the user granted
permission.
So maybe this is API misuse or
race condition.  Either way,
it's a common error that many
other developers are
experiencing and I know exactly
how to solve it right here.
There is documentation that
points to what I'm doing wrong
and how to address it.
So, huge timesaver.  Saved us a
lot of time debugging and
looking through documentation.
So if you get a crash and it has
insight on it, I definitely
recommend you take a aspect make
sure that you read up on what it
is telling you to do because it
could save you a ton of time as
well.
Now if this crash didn't have an
insight
on it, there was another great
integration you could have used
for free out-of-the-box with
crash littics, is what we call,
breadcrumbs.
So crash  littics automatically
integrates with Google Analytics
for Firebase and when a crash
occurs, we send through all the
events that were recorded in
that session.
So, what the actions the user is
doing, so you can see here there
is a bunch of screen views and
the last thing in this session
was the user tried to access the
image picker controller.  Which
makes sense because if you think
back to the crash, or what the
problem was at the insight
telling us, is that we were
trying to access the camera role
before they granted permission.
So, even if we didn't have the
insight on to this crash, we
could have probably
retraced the user steps with
breadcrumbs got ourselves into
that same scenair arrow.  These
are two great things you get
out-of-the-box to upon had you
debug.
But we wanted to step up our
debugging game by adding more
metadata and adding more are
code to the App and one of those
things we used was what we call,
custom keys.
Now, you can think of custom
keys as like contextural queues
to what is going on in the
application.  So maybe that is
the level of the game.  Level
equals 10.  Maybe that's a
really buggy level.  Or how many
items the user stored in the
shopping cart.  Because maybe
those are indicative of what is
going on and what the problem is
with the application.
And in our case, we had a hunch
there was something going on
with what we thought the
indexies of posts were in the
database versus locally on the
device when trying to delete
them.
We thought something was getting
out of sync and causing a crash.
We wanted to understand that
context so instrumented custom
keys.  Here is an example.
One line of code logging the key
for
our function and the same things
in our update deletes function.
You can download this in GitHub
but I wanted to highlight how
simple that was.
And it shows up in crash littics
like this.  So, right in the
same area you see the stack
trace and the breadcrumbs, you
canny see the keyys and what he
we
thought at the time of the crash
was for intdecks and database
this helped us debug a super
tricky crash.  So something I
recommend taking advantage of
for yourself when you want to
know context of what is going on
when the App is crashing.
Now another thing we used was
what is called user identifier.
This is something that your
customer support team will
really, really like.
So setting user identifiers is
similar to custom keys, one line
of code.  And it shows up in
crash littics like this.  Now
that might not look super useful
at first but what can you do is
map that
user ID to the user that is
logged in or using your
application so when someone
writes in to customer support
and says, hey, I'm having a bad
experience or the App always
crashes to me when I try to do
X, Y or Z, you can rectify their
situation.  Maybe retrace their
steps with breadcrumbs, issue
them a refund, tell them they
need to update their version.
Turn a negative experience into
a positive experience really
super charge your debugging
capabilities.
So those are a few extra things
you can do in addition to the
out-of-the-box insights in
breadcrumbs with custom keys and
user IDs for crash littics.
What I'm going to do now is turn
it back to tally to review
everything we did to improve the
performance and stability of
friendly picks.
>> Tally: Thank you.
So that was our full journey and
we know it was just one example
of what this could like like for
all of you.  We started coming
up with an idea and coding up an
App.  It was really exciting.
We partnered early with Firebase
test lab to make sure we had a
high-quality experience and we
could ship to the App Store with
confidence.  After we shipped to
the App Store, we depended
heavily on Firebase crash
littics and performance to make
sure we had the best possible
experience.
We were able to alert to new
issues quickly, triage and
resolve them fast.  We saw
growth of our App and expanded
to new markets.
And we dug in deeper with
advanced features.  We did all
of this so that you could focus
on what you really want to focus
on most, which is building new
features and delighting your
users.
We know no one wants to spend
their day worrying about the
quality and stability of their
App and that is why we created
these tools.  So we are able to
have your back so you can focus
on what you want to do most.
We also have your back when it
comes to security and privacy.
We are excited by may 25, we
will be
fully GDPR compliant so you can
continue to serve your users no
matter where I that are in the
world because we know that is
really important.
Thank you very much for coming
today.  We really appreciate
your time.  If you want to dig
in deeper with test lab, there
is another session tomorrow at
9:30 a.m. on autonomous and
customized prelaunch testing.
It should be really cool so
check it out.  Thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
>> Realtime captions on this
screen.
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time,
please find your seat.
We will begin soon.
ANNOUNCER: At this time, please
find your seat.  We will begin
soon.
>> MYLES BORINS: Hi, thank you
very much for joining us today.
How are you doing?  Todayy woo
are going to be  talking to
you about growing your App on
GCP.
First I'd like to introducaga.
A developer advocate.
Aga loves Ruby, dinosaurs,
robots and of course cats.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: Miles is a
developer advocate on the Cloud
team with me and she also the
Director of the Nosed technical
steering committee and loves
music and getting down with his
tech friends.
Earlier this week we stumbled
across dim somand had to pause
our rehearsal and had to have
dumplings before we could
continue.
>> MYLES BORINS: I had them all.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: We spent part
of our careers at startups for
both of us.
Y we know what it is like to
growing it in adapting it as
your user base shifts.  We know
picking the right tools for the
job at the right time is a
balancing act of costs versus
benefits versus skillsets.  And
today we are here to show you
that the Google Cloud Platform
has products that will work for
you no matter what phase you're
at and what your current
struggles are.
>> MYLES BORINS: So, once upon a
time,
there was a start-up.
Cat facts.  Has anyone heard of
cat facts before?  Raise your
hands.  A few of you.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: We might be
old, miles.
>> MYLES BORINS: This might be
an old joke.  Cat facts is a
service about getting facts
about cats.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: So some quick
facts about our cat facts App.
We already have an MVP.  We are
running on some provider
somewhere in a VM because
originally we were running on my
laptop and we have
some OS and the database and App
are all running in that
environment because that's how I
had it on my laptop and we are
using Node because of miles and
we
are using some no SQL database.
I don't want to have do deal
with  dealing with the schema as
we are rapidly iterating.
And we are doing e-mail
integration through a thursday
party because I don't want to
deal with email.
>> MYLES BORINS: So like cats,
the  VMs we use are a little
temperamental.  We only have one
at a time.  It's very precious.
But it also can get kind of
angry if you try to pet it too
quickly.  And we really have to
take care of it.  There is no
real rooms with you have a
single Virtual Machine for
errors.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: So miles is
going to show us quick what the
MVP looks like because most of
you are not familiar
with the joy that is cat facts.
>> MYLES BORINS: As you can see
here, we have cat facts.  You're
going to sign up with your
e-mail address and I'm going to
make one up.
OMG  cats@cats.biz.
We are going to submit it and we
subscribed to cat facts and get
a
response letting us know we have
successfully subscribed and
every day
we'll get an e-mail with a new
fact and a new cat with a new
cat fact.
Back to youaga.
>> AJA HAMMERLY: Thank you,
miles.  So, our cat facts App
wants to move to the Cloud.  And
we are going to be using GCP
because we are here at Google.
O.  So what are the reasons why
people want to move?  A lot of
the reasons is  people's
investors want them to.  They
know it gives you a lot of
flexibility to grow rapidly if
your App takes off and it's also
relatively easy of what the
costs will be.  People are
comfortable with it now.  You
might also want to move to the
Cloud because you don't have an
opposite team.  Our App, it's
just the two of us.  We don't
have an opposite team and you
might want to move to GCP
because you trust Google.  You
know it's running on the same
hardware and data center is
where we run YouTube and search
and Gmail and we keep those up
so we should be able to keep
your App up too.
So, we have a VM to run VMos on
GCP works will be using Google
Compute Engine.  This is on the
Cloud service.
We can make an exact combination
of CP.
And ram right for serving our
cat facts.  So I'm going to pick
something that looks like my DEV
box because I know that works.
>> MYLES BORINS: So, if we want
to move a VM over to Google
Cloud Platform, there is a
couple of different ways to
do T we can spit out a fresh VM
and build everything up or try
to find a way to orchestrate it
through tools such
asancible chef or puppet, or
have file system images you move
over.  But it's going to be a
manual process
to move this over.  So VMs are
awesome.  And there is a lot of
things that I like about VMs.
You have really fast start up
times so you can see from the
second that you spin up the VM
it will be like 30 seconds until
it is available and ready to use
and once it is running, it's
available all the time.  You
don't have to worry about how
fast it will boot off after
that.  From that, you can ma
make images and quickly boot up
in the future at any
time and customize the specks.
How much memory, CPU, and really
dial it in.  If you need
graphics cards you can do that.
If you need  TPUs for doing
sensor flow, you can do that.
It's extremely flexible.  Make
it as big or small as you want
and it's very familiar.
So if you know the  winders
server, just get that spun up
quickly and,
working in an environment you
know.
>> AJA: So a list of stuff to
consider here.  We have to
consider process management,
security updates, upgrades, we
need to consider scaling.  We
have to be responsible for doing
all of those security patches.
If something bad happens, I
don't know how many of you were
working in the industry when
heart bleed happened but I was
working consulting at that point
and it was a very frantic
morning for us as we patched a
whole bunch of VMs.  You also
know you have to do backups and
disaster recovery and
provisioning and you have to do
database replication
and that's my least favorite
task.  And our opposite team is
just the two of us.  And we
don't have the time to deal with
all of that stuff.  So, we are
going to move to highly-managed
services.
Specifically I want to start
with the database because I
don't want to do database
replication.
So we'll move to Google's
databases where we can get
services like that and
disaster recovery taken care of
us for us.
Google has SQL options and Cloud
SQL
and we support My SQL and post
crest.  And if you have
something that is similar
high-throughput and you need to
do a lot of writes, nude
consistency and you need to be
global scale, we have Cloud
Spanner, which is amazing.
It can do so much stuff and it
almost violates the cap fair but
not quite.
And then data store, our no SQL
option
what we are going to be useing
in this demo and then fire
store, which is not on the slide
but is part of fire way and
similar to data store.
>> MYLES BORINS: Now we have the
database moved over, we want to
figure out where to run the
application.
How many people in the audience
used App Engine before?
Awesome!
So you know all the amazing
benefits about moving to uponna
engine.  It's our managed
platform as a service.
We love App Engine because there
is no ops.  It has integrated
data store.  When you deploy on
App Engine, you have https
already ready for you.  You have
idiomatic run times.  I love
this as a NodeJS developer.  I
can write my App and test it
locally and deploy to the Cloud.
It will run exactly the way I
expect it to run.  And if I need
to run it somewhere else it will
just work.
Also, all the container images
we use for App Engine flex are
available on GitHub so if you
want to fork them, add to them,
it's easy for you to do that.
>> AJA: So, now we have got
someone else dealing with the
operations of our App and we
demo for you but the demo for
showing it runnings on App en
judge in is, nothing changed so
we'll skip that part.  So now we
can factor out bits of our App
and add new features, which is
what I really want to be doing.
I want to make cool stuff and I
don't want to deal with pagers.
So, first thing we'll pull out
is your App mails you cat facts
and Weis don't
really have to run the mailer in
the frontend on the same machine
so miles will tell us what to do
next with the mailer.
>> MYLES BORINS: So, when we
originally wrote this
application for our MVP, as we
said, we have everything.  The
database was in the VM.  The
single Node App did everything.
And this isn't super flexible.
It's not going to scale nicely.
It's not going to have nice
abstractions and it won't be
reusable.
One of the first things we
decided to extract out was our
cat facts as a service.
So we were able to go and maybe
AJA, do you want to get into and
describe it?
>> AJA: I'm going to show you,
we moved all of our stuff to
Cloud Functions like miles said.
We moved the mailer and we also
moved some other stuff there but
the first thing we need to do is
build out a function to get us
cat facts.  So this is some code
to retrieve cat facts from the
database and a picture to go
with it.
You can see we are just doing
basicca data star queries here
and we are ordering and pulling
one thing back and I have
updated time stamps and then we
just send back a very basic JSON
payload and a status Code of
2000.  It really took 10 minutes
to write this code and most of
that was remembering how data
store and Java script worked
together.
Miles was talking about the
e-mails so he will go into the
code for e-mail and talk about
how we approached that.
>> MYLES BORINS: So part of the
reason
we decided to move the e-mail
tore a Cloud function is because
e-mail is not a service that is
running in hot code.  It's not
going to necessarily affect the
user experience.  So you saw the
demo where I signed up with my
e-mail address.  I want to get
the response from the server
giving me confirmation we signed
up once your e-mail address is
in data store.  Once that is
done, we don't need to wait for
a e-mail to go out to send a
confirmation to the user.
So we send a message out on
Pub/Sub to send an  e-mail.
We have a generic e-mail server
that creates a client and sends
a request
with the data to who the e-mail
is going to and who is e-mailing
it and the subject and the body.
This can be reused throughout
our application.  So the exact
same Cloud function is running
to send an e-mail who you
subscribe and also sending an
e-mail every single day whenever
new facts go out.  And by
splitting it out into a Cloud
function, it's able to scale up
with our load as we have more
people subscribing.  It's able
to be used for different things.
And it's able to believe its own
code we can think about
independently.  And if we ever
want to change our e-mail Serbs
for example, we can just change
the Cloud function as long as we
adhere to the same API, the rest
of the services don't need to
change at all.
>> AJA: And so we talked about
adding new features and one of
the things I wanted to add was
cat facts bot because I really
like Chat bots.  They are a lot
of fun.  And our team uses hang
outs Chat which is sooner cool.
And so I written a Hangouts Chat
bot and one of the bring things
both the mailer and the bo the
use the same underlying cat
facts service and all of the
Hangouts Chatted bot does is
reformats the facts and picture
payload into the form that
Hangouts Chat requires.  All I
have to do is call out to the
cat facts service, get a fact
back, and then send back a 200
with the JSON
package the exact way the
Hangouts Chat expects it.  And
it was really fast and easy.
Because it's running in Cloud
Functions, if 100,000 people hit
my
Hangouts Chat bot to get their
cat facts at the same time, it's
fine.  And if no one wants cat
facts right now, that's also
fine.  Cloud function has scale
automatically to what I need at
the time.  And so, I really like
it because I don't know if cat
facts is going to take off.
Maybe people don't want cat
facts in their Chat box.
But miles can show you that Chat
bot right news.  And you're
going to see pictures of my
cats.
>> MYLES BORINS: Here you can
see we are
in Hangouts Chat and we have a
bot.
I can go like, hey bot, give me
aicality.  And the bot will
think about it for a second it's
making a call to the Cloud
function and getting the data
and it comes back with a cat and
a fact that each cat and owner
have their own unique
vocabulary.
And we can message it again,
hey, more cats.  And we give it
a second to think about a new
cat and a new fact and it gets
back to us with the same cat.
And the same fact.  And that is
how you know this is a real
demo.
[ Laughs ]
Back to you AJA.
>> AJA: So, what happened is we
have -- I hadda a time out.  I
did not sufficiently put enough
time in my Chat bot to do the
update on my query because we
are trying to pull the most
recently used.  I spent time
debugging that yesterday but I'm
sorry you saw the broken
version.  But you know it's
real.  So miles will talk a
little bit about the
architecture we ended up with.
And then we'll talk about one of
the last compute options you
have available on  GCP.
>> MYLES BORINS: So, we have
been talking through all these
different services but thought
this diagram would give a clear
idea of how we architected it.
We have a frond ent running on
App Engine taking user requests
and when you
sign up, it is adding a user and
then requesting a cat fact from
the cat fact
function and then submitting an
event to
Pub/Sub to let it know this in
an  e-mail.
Pub/Sub is triggering the
function listening for new
e-mail events and e-mailing it
out.  The task  scheduler is
another App Engine App.  If you
didn't know, you can actually
make cron jobs using App Jen sin
to set
up it to sex cute App Engine
rest calls besides certain
amounts of time.  So the task
scheduler is set to run on a
daily basis.  It gets a list of
all the people who subscribed
every day and then sets a new
task in the Pub/Sub queue for
every single person to send them
a new fact.
The e-mailer goes and grabs the
cat fact and sends it out.  What
is really cool about this too is
you will notice we have multiple
services calling to the cat
facts service.
We have the chalet bot also
calling and we can build a whole
fleet of services depending on
the kind of service you want to
use.
We can make e-mailers, SMS, Chat
bots, IRC bots, and they can all
use the same microservice to
scale up based on how much load
there is.  Maybe we find out
that people don't like e-mail
anymore and we need to piaffes
on the to SMS.  We are ready to
do that and don't have to do
much refactorring to our
architecture to support that.
>> AJA: That the point, let's
just pretend that cat facts is
the new  hotness and it is
wildly successful and we have
hundreds of millions of users
gets the cat pictures on a daily
basis.  So if that happens,
which we hope will happen, we
will be able to hire someone to
help us with operations.  And
when I talked to my friends in
operations, one of them said, we
need to consider Google
Kubernetes everyone gin.  I was
talking to her about it and said
it will give us more flexibility
with
our architecture while retaining
many of the benefits of App
Engine Cloud functions and
especially work well for us
because we already moved towards
our microservices architecture
with a bunch
of different scalable
components>> MYLES BORINS: You
may be asking yourself, what is
a Kubernetes?  How many people
in the audience used Kubernetes
so far?  So you're not asking
what is a Kubernetes.
But for those who haven't,
Kubernetes
is the Greek word for Helms man.
And it is a service that is
open-source.
It's in the CNCF, Cloud data
compute foundation and it is for
orchestrating and scaling Docker
containers and production.  It's
a way of setting up Cloud
architecture and designed and
based on the Google internal
architecture polar.  So a lot of
the lessons and things we
learned about making scalable
services, were all used to
inspire the
architecture of Kubernetes.
On our next slide we will show
what
aiama file looks like for
Kubernetes.
>> AJA: Here is a example for
engine X container.
The big thing to be aware of,
this is something folks found
challenging.  Unlike when you're
doing scripting to
make your VMs  reproducible, all
of that is focused on the how
and you want to install this
thing and this thing and change
these ports and set up this kind
of load balancer.  Kubernetes
you need to describe what a
happy, wonderful, good state is
for your product.
This many versions of this
container, this many versions,
and this kind of load balancer
and Kubernetes does
everything in its 4 keep that
happy state.  So if one of your
Nodes magically one of your VMs
gets hit by lightening in the
center of your data center,
Kubernetes will take what was
running on that Node and put it
to other places in
a way to make sure that your App
is as close to that running
state that happy state that you
want it to be.  And it takes a
little bit of work for a lot of
peoples to get their head around
the fact you don't explain how
to get there.  You use the
concepts built into Kubernetes,
pods, services, deployments, to
describe what a successfully
running App looks like.
So, miles mentioned it a bit. In
that example I was using the
engine X Docker container.  What
is a Docker?  One of the things
I asked when people
are trying to teach me about
Kubernetes.
And Docker is a conner format
and the
container is a way of packaging
up run time and the files in the
dependency to go with it.
You can put multiple of them on
a VM and don't have to deal with
dependency conflicts.  When I
was  working in opposite, one of
the things we had was three
different parts of the
microservices and they were each
releasing slightly different
versions of Ruby gems or various
sea libraries and installing
them together side-by-side was a
problem and we had to get three
teams to agree on which version
we were going to standardize on.
With Docker you can package up
an App and run it next to an App
with very different dependency
on the same machine and you get
much better utilization and you
get safety.  The other nice
thing about using containers and
Docker is that since you're
packaging a container, you seem
to have less for example with
the works in DEV and doesn't
work in prod situation.  Which I
spent many hours banging my head
against.  And when you read
about this, you'll see stuff
about name spaces and sea
groups and all that but the big
thing
is, running application withings
key pendency and file system
packaged up neatly.
>> MYLES BORINS: What you can
see on the screen now is fairly
straightforward Docker file.  We
are starting from an image that
is published by the NodeJS
project.
Carbon is the eight.X branch for
LT.
And if you go from NodeJS:
Carbon-Alpine, we will grab the
latest published version running
on an App  pine-based operating
system is.  It's a very, very
thin operating system designed
specifically for running in
Docker containers.
If you're looking for fast boots
and thin images, Alpine is a
good place tow get started.  We
are copying the file system from
the folder we are running in
directly into the image and we
will run the command, MPM and
install production.  That
production flag makes sure
you're DEV dependency don't get
installed and it's important to
run all of the commands to set
up your environment before
you're running in production.
So this will make sure all the
dependency you need are there,
there there ising in in that
image you don't need for running
in that production and then the
command MPM start will boot
everything up.  That command
gets run when the Docker
container is started.  MPM start
is a really great way to boot
things up.  It's something you
pult in your backage JSON
script.  If anyone has more
questions about Best Practices
for setting up Node
applications, please feel free
to grab
me after the talk.
>> AJA: One of the things I
mentioned in my definition of
Docker is sea group.  What is a
sea group?  That's out of scope
for this talk.
So you can come talk to me --
there is
container office hours and also
office hours on Google Cloud's
open-source projects in the
office hours space and folks
from the Kubernetes project will
be there if you want to talk in
detail about the implementation.
So, why would you maic the
switch to Kubernetes?  This is
the question I get the most when
I'm in the field talking to
folks at events or at meet-ups
and you don't have to.  There is
a lot of folks who are like,
Kubernetes is the new holtness,
I have to use Kubernetes.  If
what you have works for you,
great.
App Engines, Cloud Functions or
VMs or any combination of those
like we had
with our cat facts App, they are
a fine way to run your App
indefinitely.  If if works don't
fix it.  But containers provide
some advantages around
portability, predictability and
utilization.  And I have seen a
lot of success with teams that
have switched to this.  The big
thing I seen from my friends is
they are getting better
utilization out of their VMs.
Able to use all the CP.
And all the memory they
provision.
It's less of an issue with GCP
because
it lets you make custom VMs that
exactly fit your App.  But if
you have things that are really
variable in load or you have a
bunch of VMs that look the same
for whatever reason, containers
might be a way to solve that
problem.
And if you decided to go with
containers for any of theser
other reasons, Kubernetes is a
great way of managing the
problem of making sure that
everything stays up.  If you
specify known good state, it
will take care of making that
known good state maintained even
if something wierd happens to
some of your machines.
>> MYLES BORINS: So, some
concluding thoughts about all
the things we just said.
Google Cloud Platform is kind of
like a delicious buffet.  Bear
with me on this.  You have lots
of different ones and you can
pick them all depending on your
tastes.  As you need more, they
are there.  They are on the
cart.  They are steamed.  They
are ready to go.  You need more
Summey, we have more.  And it's
really easy to share.  You have
big projects, you can add more
people to the projects, they can
grab the dumplings they want.
I'm really hungry.
[ Laughs ]
>> AJA: Almost lunch time.
>> MYLES BORINS: I know almost
about dumplings.  But I just
want to eat them not think about
how to make them.  That's a
great benefit about this
platform.  You if you need to
focus on the MVP and the product
you're getting out the door and
your product isn't operations
you may want to use all these
things that are ready to go.
You can iterate off them as
necessary and make decisions to
make sure that you're not super
locked into things that are
harder to move.  But we have a
lot of different products
available for you today to run
your compute in 5U8 sorts of
different ways based on your
needs.
>> AJA: So we went through a lot
of stuff really requestic looy
and one of the thick I want to
make sure everyone knows, if you
choose one of these things it
doesn't mean you can't change
your mind later on.  All of
these things play well together.
Here is kind of the  high-level
summary of what we talked about.
We have Google Compute Engine.
Virtual machines in custom
sizes.  I was talking to someone
and they had done the math.
There is over 6000 different
ways to configure it.
6000 different flavors of VM.
So who ships something on a VM?
I have lots and lots of times.
That's fewer folks than I
expected.  Or if you want to
pick up something that you're
running in a V month.
Your local machine and shove it
into production.  We have Google
App Engine.  This is a
serverless application platform.
It's good when you want to no
opposite solution to running
youre App and want fully-managed
services.  You want networking
and auto-scaling
and the ability to use images
that are known good that Google
has endorsed and we want to make
sure we are maintaining and
patching and things like that.
We have Google Cloud functions
for
event-driven serverless
applications or event-driven
parts of your application.  This
is good for tasks that need high
scale some of the time and
largely stateless.  Especially
if you have something you need
to run a lot at once and not a
lot later on.  Because you can
shove as much through that pipe
as you need to or as little.
Depends on what your use is and
it's great are for that and then
we have Google Kubernetes
engine.  It's managed Kubernetes
on Google Compute Engine.
This is know one of the easiest
ways to get started with
containers.  It's how I got
started and it's really good
because we take care of a lot of
the stuff for you.  Lots of
folks are involved in the
Kubernetes projects inside and
outside Google, Google is very
involved and the team that build
Google Kubernetes engine works
with the team that is working on
Kubernetes to make sure that
Erving is smooth.  So we want to
say thank you and before
we say thank you for all
attending, I'd like to thank the
folks who are making this
possible.  We have fantastic
staff running the lights and
camera and producing in this
room.  So if you could give them
a round of applause, I would be
grateful.
[ Applause ]
And thank you all for coming and
giving
us 45 minutes of your wonderful
day today at Google I/O.  I hope
you have a wonderful afternoon.
>> MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Realtime captions on this
screen
>> ANNOUNCER: At this time,
please find your seat.
Our session will begin soon.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello! Welcome to our
session.  We appreciate you
choosing to spend the next 40
minutes her with us given the
number of things we have going
on at IO.  It's a busy time.
My name is Benjamin Schrom and
I'm joined by Jennifer miller
and Brittany Mennuti.
We are from the team at Google
working on immersive computing.
We want to talk about it for
teaching and learning and a few
really important and different
context.  First, I want to make
sure we are all on the same page
about what we mean by immersive
computing.
The simplest terms we mean VR
and AR.  VR that can take you
anywhere like to the Taj Mahal,
to the another place in
time, down to the atomic level,
wherever.
And AR, that can bring you
anything, a
dinosaur, a jet engine, da
Vinci's 15th century design for
a helicopter or just information
about the world around you.
But the reason we say and will
continue to say immersive
computing is that at Google we
look at these technologies as
occupying different areas in a
shared spectrum and all points
on this spectrum are beginning
to blur together more and more.
So the plan today to spend a few
minutes  walking through
specifically why and how we see
this Technology being used for
teaching and learning and again
we really mean teaching and
learning in the broadest sense.
So I'll share updates about
Google expeditions.  Jen will
talk to us about our efforts to
bring this Technology to higher
education and then finally brit
will
walk us through tour creator.
So why are we here for the third
IO in a row talking about this?
What is the big idea here?
The really powerful idea is that
we have an opportunity with
almost any
Technology on this submersive
computing spectrum to turn
things that form so
much of our education, of our
work, of how we perceive the
world, into more concrete
experiences that activate our
minds and our bodies and allow
us to learn by experience.  Sort
of a continuation of how we all
learned things as kids.
For the set of things we will
talk about today, what we want
to enable is this Technology
makes those concrete
experiences much more regular
things, must have more
accessible and effective as
possible.  This is really
important because we all need it
like our kids will need it,
future generations will need it.
So two years ago at IO, I posed
this classic math problem to the
audience and I wanted to check
back and see if anyone got the
answer in the last two years?  I
have now learned this is a
classic problem.  It's called
the age of the Captain problem.
Many, many studies have posed
this or similar sorts of
questions to primary and
secondary students.  Does anyone
have an answer?  How old the
Captain is?
It turns out, a majority of your
average sort of primary and
secondary school math students
will produce a numerical answer
to thisy request.
66 out of 97 is the most recent
study.  The researchers in that
study termed this phenomenon,
the suspension of sense
making which now I know it is a
really useful phrase in all
kinds of context
but it's the doomsday skin arrow
from when learning becomes too
abstracted.  And it illustrates
the challenge and opportunity we
have before us.
The opportunity is that instead
of asking a student like why
they should
spend time studying why ancient
Rome was important or asking
them to appreciate these amazing
artifacts of human history with
little pictures in a textbook or
a video on a little screen, you
can let them explore it in VR
like they were there in Rome.
You can give them this
bite-sized field trip moment
that  engages their
mind and body and gives them
thage to look around.  Or you
can let them evaluate statue of
a powerful woman in history like
Cleopatra like it was standing
right in front of them.
Another way to think about this
is that a Thiry popular among
cognitive scientists who study
learning, cognitive
load theory, people heard of
this?  It says that like our
ability to learn if you think
about it like a funnel,
basically the total mental
energy that we have to learn
something is what is left over
after you subtracted the
inherent difficulty of the thing
you're trying to understand and
learn, plus the effort required
to understand how that concept
is presented.  So what you're
left with is the mental energy
left to learn.  So if fractions
has inherent
difficulty of X, it's like other
difficulty of Y that is just
like trying to understand how
fractions are  presented to you
or how it is taught to you.
We can't do much about the
interaren't difficulty of these
concepts.  The world is a
complicated place.  But we can
do something about that orange
part of the funnel but how
information is presented to
people when they are trying to
learn it.
When you look at so many of the
place that is learning happens,
like classrooms and lecture
halls, they really aren't set up
to like lesson cognitive load.
They are basically only set up
to explain things with words or
2HD drawings.  And then you
realize that not a lot changed
in hundreds of years like this
is how we were teaching people
in the 15th century.
And for us it seems like using
seem overdue.  So let's start
with talking about Google
expedition.
We launched expeditions at IO
three years ago and it's been
incredible to watch it grow and
now 10s and tens of thousands of
schools are using it every
single day.  Expeditions hasn't
changed much from how we first
conceived it.  It's a tool that
allows a teacher, or
a guide, to take groups of
co-located students on virtual
field trips or show them virtual
things.
Since we announced it in 2015,
we have continued to see it grow
and continued to add features to
make it more powerful and even
more accessible.  And as of
today, we are really excited to
show over 3 million students and
teachers have participated in
one of our pioneer programs and
it's been installed on over 6
million device system and we are
so encouraged by the excitement
we see from teachers and
students who have
been using it for multiple years
now.
In addition, to the steady
stream of qualitative feedback
we received, we have also
started to get real
quantitative data back as well.
And it is still early days for
this stuff but in a recent
study, we worked
with SRI researchers and found
that students that used
expeditions VR as
part of a specific science
lesson outperformed those
students who used
that same lesson but with
traditional 2D media like
pictures and video and they did
so by statistically significant
number.
So I wanted to share a few of
the thick we learned along the
way and some things
that we are doing to makes
expeditions better and more
accessible.
So first, cardboard my be an
awesome material to build a
universally available VR headset
but not the best to
build a VR kit to schools to
use.  This is the first kit box
made in 2015 and we were so
Excited when it arrived.  We
thought it was the coolest thing
ever.
We had cardboard headsets and a
cardboard kit.  That was our
cardboard box of two hours in a
classroom.  Big surprise, right?
Classrooms are harsh
environments for Technology.  So
we knew we had to bring on
Partners to help us and today we
have kits like
this in school across the world.
Who wishes that I had a VR cart
in their class instead of a TV
cart?  Me too.  We now have over
10 different Partners
offering kits in over a dozen
different countries.  We also
learned that if we want to reach
the most number learners
possible with Technology like VR
and AR, we need to remove as
many Aztec logical prerequisites
as possible.  We started by
allowing expeditions to work off
line so that even in schools
like this Juan in Ghana, they
could travel the world with VR.
Or in the school hundreds of
Myles up the Amazon river, they
could go outside and compare
their environment to ones all
the way across the world.
So last year, we removed another
pre-rec sit and made it works
for users who didn't find
themselves in a classroom or in
a group.
We have seen lots and lots of
teachers uses this solo mode in
their classes to let their
students explore the world on
their own.
We'll soon be updating the home
screen to make self-guided tours
much easier to discover and jump
into.  While still making it
simple and straightforward to
use in class.
We also have been making some
really
amazing new content like the set
of expeditions we made with the
Earth VR
team that brings the experience
of  seeing Google earth in VR
and daydream and it is made
available in ser at.  It allows
you to take a highly
complicated 3D mesh like the
scene of Google Earth from New
York City and simplifies it down
to a scene that within a limited
head box, can be viewed on
mobile VR devices.  It's really
powerful stuff.  And it's
especially really powerful
stuff on the recentee announced
la novo solo device.  These
expeditions really come alive
with the 6 degrees of freedom
you get with a mirage.  And we
continued to add just more and
more engaging and interesting
content to epetitions.
We have over 800 expeditions
spanning history, stem subjects,
art, there is something for
everyone, every teacher
and student and eve curious
adult.
You also continue to partner
with the real experts in the
field of educational
publishing like HMH, a series of
expeditions that supplement
their textbooks and as we were
discussing, make all that
important information contained
within the textbook become more
accessible and concrete with the
set of acutching VR content.
But most importantly, we learned
that when you take students to
amazing
places, like under water or
among choral Reeves, they really
want to investigate
the things they see there.  Like
choral.  Or  sharks.  They want
to get up close.  I that want to
take the opportunity to look
this guy in the eye.
To look at the rows of sharp
teeth.
So expeditions AV our answer for
how you bring that shark into
the classroom such as everyone
remains dry and intact.  We give
you a preview of the AR last
year at IO and we spent the last
year taking our Beta application
around to schools all over the
world.
Over one million students and
teachers participated in our
bait.  They gave us their
thoughts and helped us refine it
and improve it.  We wanted to
take this chance to thank them
for such thoughtful feedback,
for seeing through some of the
early rough
Edges and for just inspiring us
to build it each and every day.
And check out #google
expeditions on Twitter if you
want to seea mazing scenes of
people using expeditions AR.
The feedback we received has
been super encouraging like this
9th grade teacher from Boise,
Idaho W.H.O. saw her classroom
come alive.
We love that last part in the
quote, most of  all.  Students
have become both the teacher and
the learner.
And this is really the Holy
Grail giving amazing teachers
like Karen the technological
instruments to make moments like
this happen in her classroom.
So expeditions AR will be
shipping a major update to our
already launched
App, ARL live along V R and
shipping it at the end of the
month with 100 different AR
expeditions composed of the
objects that span the same
breath our VR tours do.
I want to give you a quick run
through of the futures we will
be  launching with.
First, as we do in VR, one of
the most powerful tools we can
give a guide is the ability to
draw the group's attention to
specific areas or points of
interest.  But we needed to
design a new way to point out
parts of the object.  So we
built a spotlight light feature
that let's a teacher shine a
light on part of the object such
that all of the students can see
it.  The teacher can move that
spotlight around.  They can make
it a pinpoint or a floodlight.
It looks really cool.
We also learned that the bigger
the elephant, the better.  But
the spaces people have available
to them are all different sizes.
So you need to be able to
quickly resize it and let that
propagate to all
the connected devices.
And while we don't use markers
for tracking, we learned that
physical marker images can be a
great way of establishing a
common reference point for large
groups viewing the same  object.
So with expeditions, you can put
down eight different markers
around your space and the
objects you choose to show your
group will display on top of
them.  This helps to ensure you
don't have 30 kids crowded
around the same object.
And just like we have a solo
mode in VR, we values a solo
mode in AR.  So if you weren't
guiding a group, you don't need
a marker.
Just tap on any plane your
device detectives to place that
object and have a look and you
have all the explanatory
information in a card to read
about.
Like who doesn't want  the -- on
their table?
So as I said before, expeditions
AR will be shipping at the end
of the month as
an update to current
application.  No need to install
anything new.
You will need an AR enabled
device like a pixel.  For
schools that love their VRits
and there are more and more of
them, that's by education we
will be offering a best of both
words.  VR and AR kit.  This
device does high-quality AR and
the VR just beautifully.
We are also really excited to
announce
that the recently debuted acer
Chrome
tab 10, the first Chrome OS
tablet
designed for use in schools,
will be supporting VR core and
expeditions  AR.  And for those
schools with iPads,
we'll also be bringing the same
updates to the iOS App and just
like Cloud anchors you may have
heard of earlier, it will cork
across platform so you can use
an Android device to guide an
iOS device or vice versa.  So
that is it for expeditions.  A
beautiful new UI.
A powerful set of AR features
and a bunch of AR content to go
with it.
It's basically a museum in your
pocket.
So we are going to change gears
--
[ Applause ]
We are excited too.  Thank you!
Beyond K12 learning, we are
seeing lots of signs this
Technology can create engaging
experiences for University
students.  And to talk to you
about  that, I'd
like to introduce Jen.
>> JENNIFER HOLLAND: Thank you,
Ben.  Beyond the curriculum, we
quickly learned that there was
even broader learning
opportunities with VR.
In the same way that learning
can be an abstraction for many
students, going to college,
pursuing different careers is an
abstraction for students around
the world.  These students don't
have access to the mentors and
the professionals in their life
that have experience going to
college or have experience
pursuing different careers.
So, for the past few years, we
have been creating hundreds of
college and career expeditions
to enable students to be able to
visual use what it is like
taking that step across that
graduation stage and accepting
that diploma.  Or taking that
first step in applying for that
dream job.
And along the same lines, many
educational programs have not
been traditionally represented
by women and minorities.
And it can be difficult for
these students to imagine what
did is like to participate in
these programs.
But we know VR can help with
this.  One school, the New York
tan den school of engineering,
has taken this to a completely
another level.  They were
looking to improve the impact
and the diversity of their
in-coming freshman class so they
created
a VR App and they enlisted the
help of students and faculty and
built a bunch of different
experiences showcasing the
different projects and programs
happening on their campus.
And the admissions team created
these cardboard, sent out a
letter to students with
instructions on how to download
the VR App.
And apart from doing this, to
separate themselves from other
schools, the immersive
experience mainly highlighting
the work of female students and
faculty and narrated by a woman,
has helped to
increase the female acceptance
rate of
students by over 10% in just two
years.  Come on!  We can cheer
for that.
[ Applause ]
It's so impressive.  When the
admissions office surveyed
that  in-coming class, many
cited the VR App as one of the
reasons why they chose the New
York tan den school of
engineering because they could
visualize what their 4 years
were going to be like on campus
and get to experience working
with different faculty and
students.
And beyond using VR for
admissions, we are seeing
Professors like Adam
Blumenthal from brown University
capture historical Sites using
the jump camera
and marking those videos up in
360 photos up and using tools
like blocks
and poly, to vividly re-create
important historical moments in
history.  Like the battle bee
affair which happened off the
coast of Rhode Island.  It was a
dramatic event in the lead up to
the American revolution.
Students can now walk through
this
virtual tour and experience a
preserved part of history.
But not all faculty are like
Adam and know how to build
immersive content.   So, to help
faculty and students get
started, we created a free VR
video course for anyone to be
able to take and will be
launching an AR course this
summer.
We have also provided schools
with sampled projects to help
them get inspired to how they
could build experiences using VR
and AR.  And we have also
established a hardware loan
program so that schools can
apply and get the necessary
hardware to help them get
started on their first projects.
Since launching the VR video
course and the hardware loan
program this past fall, we have
received really positive
feedback from students like
Michael who
have taken the course.  And one
thing we are seeing is that more
and more students like Michael,
are
going online to pursue an
education.
In fact, 32% of students took an
on
line course just last year.
This is a really powerful notion
that your access to a great
education is no
longer dependent on your
geographic proximity to one.
Or dependent on having all day
in-person classes.
Imagine if you wanted to pursue
a career in let's say, nursing.
And you had to take a set of
pre-rec sit courses like
biology.  And your closest
University is 200 Myles away.
You might decide it's worth it
and so you go and look up the
courses that are being offered
and you realize that biology
class is offered Monday,
Wednesday and Fridays from 1-4
p.m.
But you have a full-time job.
You're probably not likely to
register for that class and you
might also consider a different
career opportunity
that allows you more
flexibility.  Almost all degreed
granting institutions offer
courses on line.  But many
popular courses and degrees like
biology, require in-person
activities like labs.  Because
of this, schools either don't
offer those courses, ask
students to pay
really high course fees, or ask
remote students to Drive hours
to attend these in-person
activities.  It turns out this
doesn't scale.
But we know we have the
Technology to enable these
experiences.
And that is why we are excited
today to aannounce that in
partnership with labster, a
science education company in
Denmark, we have removed the
physical
lab requirements to complete an
on line biology degree using
virtual reality.
[ Applause ]
Schools will now be able to
truly offer an on line biology
degree.
The 30 labs can fully simulate
real-world outcomes using
advanced simulations and
mathematical equations
all built on the daydream
platform.
These labs are economically
efficient as a cost of the VR
headset and the content for the
lab is still cheaper than the
years of lab fees.  And it
provides scale to a growing
number of students that are
pursuing courses on line who
previously were left
out because of geographic
constraints.
Students are also able to have
unlimit the lab time, which is
something that many schools
can't offer today.
And as one student put it, I no
longer have to worry about
having a bad TA.  Students are
also able to engage on a
molecular level within these
labs, which is impossible today.
And will we are really excited
to announce that the first
University that will be offering
these VR labs to their students
is Arizona State University this
fall.
[ Applause ]
And what is also exciting is
that these
labs map to AP and IB courses
for K12 schools so schools that
want to supplement their
existing curriculum can do that.
And for those schools that can't
afford creating a whole VR
laboratory in their school, they
can offer these VR labs as a
replacement.
Labs are also connects the lab
progress with major LMS systems
including Google classroom,
which will be integrated this
fall.  And it allows teachers to
track the
progress of students throughout
these VR labs.
Labster has been able to help
reduce all of the laboratory
costs for schools by
virtualizing hundreds of
machines and equipment.
I'm not sure what this HPLC or
the PCR is, but I'm pretty sure
I can do
something fun with that
fermenter.
We think this is the beginning
of something big.
What better way to use the power
of VR than to offer a powerful
education?  And with that, I'll
hand it off to my colleague,
Brent, who will talk a little
bit more about how VR is being
used in the classroom and
beyond.
[ Applause ]
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: Thank you
very much, Jen.  Programs like
labster got us thinking.  How
could we scale this kind of
immersive learning to more
people?  And how to make it
easier to create this kind of
content?  Now we all know that
most of us don't have the
expertise to re-create a million
dollar laboratory in VR but we
also know that many of us have
things to teach.  And stories to
tell.  And since the earliest
days of expeditions, both
teachers and students have asked
for the ability to create their
own.  So we started to think
about what it would be like to
make it easier to create VR
content.
That is why in January, we
launched a Beta for students and
teachers to make their own
expeditions.  In partnership
with Rico, we outfitted students
and schools all over the globe
with Rico data 360 cameras and
kits of Chrome books,
cardboards, phones, tripods,
everything they needed to create
their own expeditions.  We
encouraged them to use the
theme, love where you live, so
they could showcase their
communities to other schools
participating in the program.
Let's take a look at the
experience of one of these
schools in Lancaster,
Pennsylvania with this quick
video.
>> I was born and raised here in
Lancaster.
>> It is a big farming
community.
>> You see family farms
everywhere you go.
>> And I think it is really cool
that we have this opportunity to
share our way of life.
>> How we are going to do this
is using a new tool called
towery creator.
>> Easy to use tool that allows
our students to create rich 360
degree experiences.
>> You will see the photos that
the Ag department and the art
department have supplied.
>> Add a title and description.
Click on that and then it will
bring up the street view.
We could plug that into the
tour.
>> It will definitely in spear
me to show more of Lancaster and
hopefully it will inspire people
to do the same.
>> And it's wonderful we can
have our
students interacting with all of
these other student stories
across the globe.
>> This is Chicago's little
village neighborhood.
>> Very close living quarters.
Very different from around here.
>> We were just looking at the
one from bally.
Their classes are basically
outside.
>> I really thought that this
was neat.
>> Everybody is different on the
way they live.
>> And every place has a unique
story.
[ Applause ]
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: One of
hundreds of schools that are
have participated in this
program.  For example, community
high school in Chicago made a
tour of Chicago's little village
showcasing the awesome arts and
the culture the village has to
offer.  And the green school in
Bali, made
this amazing tour that showcases
other students what it is like
to get an education being
completely emersed in nature,
that is right.
These students actually learn
outside.
And another school in Spain
created a
tour of all the historic Sites
to show other schools what their
community was like.
These are just a few examples of
over 300 schools that have
participated in this program.
And thanks to them, we now have
a ton of feedback about what it
is like to create your own
expeditions.
As we were thinking through that
feedback, it occurred to us,
that when it comes to this
concept that Ben mentioned
earlier, of transforming
abstract concepts to real ones,
perhaps expeditions like content
could be useful outside of the
classroom.  Let's take the
example of buying a home.  When
you're purchasing a home, you
might consult a whole Burch of
resources
like photos, brochures,
blueprints,
floor plans, in order to inform
your decision.
Now we can imagine how being
emersed in a virtual tour would
give you a much better
understanding of what it is like
to actually live there.  That is
why we are super excited today
to announce the launch of tour
creator.  A web application that
gives anyone
the power to create VR content.
As of today, students, teachers,
businesses and employees, folks
like you and me, we can all
create our own VR tours and
easily share them anywhere on
the web.
When you go to tour creator, you
start out by starting a new tour
or picking up on a draft.  And
then you add some basic metadata
like a title, description,
category and a cover photo.  And
then you fill your tour with
scenes.  Scenes are made
possible through the use of 360
photos.  If you have your own
360 photos, awesome.  You can
upload them in just a couple of
clicks.  But if you don't have
no fear, we integrated with
street view so take advantage of
the massive library of 360
photos already available in
Google Maps.
Once you add your scenes, you
add points of interest.  These
are  essentially areas of
importance that you like to
highlight and you can add a
little bit of text information
to inform your viewer.  You can
also enrich points of interest
with other media like 2D photos
and in
the future, we'll add narration
and ambient audio to help your
viewers feel like they are
actually there.  Now when you're
done creating your tour, publish
it to the web.
Make it public for anyone to
see, or unlisted so only those
with the link can see it.  When
you publish it to the web, you
actually publish it to poly.
If you're not familiar with
poly, polyis Google's library of
3D content launched late last
year.
Previously poly, had things like
3D models and sketches.
As of it, it will also contain
3D experiences in the forcement
of tours.
And this is where the true
beauty of this product comes in.
Because your publishing your
tour to the web, all you need to
do to share it is share a URL.
So that means you can view your
tour in 2D on desktop or laptop.
You can text the link to your
tour to a friend or colleague.
They can load it on their mobile
device and simply use magic
window to experience it.  Or
they can tap and enter VR button
and put to the in a Google
cardboard and immediately be
emersed in the tour you just
created.
Now you may be wondering what is
this magic?  I thought you had
to install a Burch of Apps and
get wheel really expensive
hardware.
This is made through a
Technology called web X, that
you might have heard of at the
previous IO session.  Web XR
means you can experience VR
content in your browser using
any VR headset.
Another beautiful thing about
publishing these tours to the
web is that you can easily embed
them.  Just go to poly, click on
a share button, and you'll get
an ibreak snippet to put in any
blog or website.  And when you
think about it, this can
be truly  transformational for
business.  Let's go back to the
example of real estate.
Imagine a future where instead
of seeing a series of 2D feetose
on line, instead you saw a
virtual tour of that
property that you are about to
buy.
Now you may be thinking, okay
maybe business businesses will
use this thing but will they
actually use it?  To validate we
were building the right product
we partnered with a bunch of
companies across many verticals
to get their feedback before we
launched and we want to share
with youa I few examples
of what they created.
Time out New York has been using
tour creator to create tours of
having the best day ever in New
York City.
Everything from Central Park to
Lincoln center to the New York
public library.  Imagine it
done.
A company devoted to helping its
clients like style icon Lindsay
lain,
organize their lives and their
closets, has been using tour
creator to showcase their
expertise.  Now I don't know
about you, but if I had that
many pairs of shoes, I probably
want to see a tour of how they
were
going to organize them.
REA group, owner of real estate.
com, the Number 1 place for
property in Australia, has been
using tour creator to create
tours to embed in both their
website and their Mobile Apps
soon.  As they mentioned to us,
tour creator allows their users
to explore their properties from
wherever they are.  And of
course, in broad applications if
are this Technology and
Enterprise training.  KLM
airlines has been using tour
creator to save lots of money on
training costs by acclimating
flight crews to the aircraft
before they set foot inside.
Now it's one thing to hear about
these use cases from us.  It's
another thing to hear about them
direct from the source.  Let's
doubt a quick video where we
will share their feedback.
>> Time out has awls always been
helping people explore their
city and tower creator helps us
do just that.
It is really going to help us be
able to  ibovate in the digital
world and create new content.
We have cool 360 photos and we
pop
them into tour creator and pull
images, fun facts, things to do
in that area.  Anything you need
to know, we have really cool
tours through that.
>> You can use tour creator
virtually in the aircraft which
means we can train
people whenever and wherever
they want with virtual reality.
It saves quite a bit of money.
>> We have a mission to provide
purposeful corking opportunities
and authentic vocational
experiences for individuals with
Autism.
>> Tour creator allowed us to ha
bus 8 our staff and employees
before they come
in the building, before they
make one step into our building.
Tour creator lets us show them
what to expect and become
acclimated to the
building, to the noise, to the
machinery.
>> The tour creator tool brings
everything to life.  Clients
feel so comfortable knowing what
the spaces are going to look
like by seeing it through the
tour creator tool.
It's in dispensable.
[ Applause ]
>> BRITTANY MENNUTI: Thank you.
We are super excited to launch
tour creator to all of you today
and can't wait to see all the
tours you're going to  create.
Later this year, we will be
introducing the ability to add
these
tours directly to the expedition
App so say tuned for that.
With, that I'll pass it back off
to
Ben for some Closing Remarks.
>> BENJAMIN SCHROM: Thank you,
brit.  So there you have it.
A new powerful mode in Google
expesdition that packs a
universe of places and things in
your pocket and
brings them into your classroom,
on to
your desk, on toppure of your
textbook.  A biology degree from
labster and daydream that uses
the power of immersive
com futmake access to education
no reliant on your -- and
immersive content accessible to
anyone straight from the web
browser.  I want to close on a
note about why this is so
important.  I can't really think
about education and Technology
without  thinking about this
guy.  20 years ago he observed
it might be time to reconsider
our fundamental conception of
what a literal person --
not a literal punish, a literate
person.  For hundreds of years
the primary way we have taught
things and learned things in
school was via the written word
or symbols.   Reading, writing
them.  These are obviously
critical skills for many people
they are really challenging
entry points.
They are about as abstract as
things get.  We have an
opportunity to use Technology to
lower these barriers to
make learning richer, less
abstract, to make all that
important reading and writing we
do be augmented with the parts
of the world they refer to.
And we can use photo sphere,
sounds,
3D objects and simulations and
all the formats to give learners
effective entry points to
complicated subjects and  ideas.
So here is a quote from one of
the teachers who participated in
the Beta.
It really resonated with us.  It
is something I remember seeing
every day when I have been a
teacher every day 10 years ago.
Many very, very smart students,
they
might not bring extensive
textural literacy for a Burch of
different reasons.  Language
bears, educational background.
We we treat this like it say
blocker to their  learning, we
don't have to.  We view  all,
and we all have an opportunity
to use all these tools.
VR and AR to give them a more
natural, more inherently visual
entry point to really important
ideas in learning.  And as this
teacher says, we can help to
level the playing field.  So
thank you very much!
[ Applause ]
Bringing AI and machine learning
innovations to health healthcare
My name is Lily Peng.
I'm a physician by training and
I work
medical -- Lgoogle  AI
healthcare team.
I am a Product Manager and today
we're
you about a couple of projects
that we
have been working on in our
group.
lot of this.
So I'm not going to go over this
too much.
because we apply deep learning
to medical information, I kind
of wanted to
get used quite a bit, but are
some what defined.
This is a pretty broad term and
build non-human intelligence.
Machine learning is a particular
type
suppose, that teaches machine to
be -- teaches machines to be
smarter.
particular type of machine
learning
which you guys have probably
heard about quite a bit.
So it's a modern  reincarnation
of
networks which was invent in the
1960s.
It's a collection of simple,
trainable
layers and they work together to
solve a model complicated tasks.
data sets and compute which we
had in
the 1980
's and '90s, they work with
larger data
compute power, we find that
neuro networks work much better.
aways that I want you guys to
get from this slide.
deep learning trains algorithms
which
are very accurate when given
enough data.
learn category do this without
feature engineering.  And that
means without explicitly rules.
Well, in traditional computer
vision,
the rules that machines should
follow to make a certain
prediction task.
networks, we spend very little
time in feature engineering and
writing these rules.
time we spend in data
preparation, numerical
optimization and model
architecture.
question quite a bit and the
question
is:  How much data is enough
data for a deep neuro network?In
general, more is better, but
there are diminishing returns
beyond a certain point.
rule of thumb is that we like to
have
about 5,000 positives per class
and but and relevant data.
So garbage in, garbage out.  The
model will predict very well
what
predict.
when you think about where
machine
deep learning can make the
biggest impact, it's really in
places where through.
One of our directors, Greg Carr
rato put its best.
you have done T*EFRPB,000 times
and on
the 10,001st time, you don't
want to do it anymore.You are
sick of it.  This is really good
in screening applications when
you see a lot of
that are potentially normal.
So here on the right, you see a
graph
of the shortage of
This is forever other medical
specialties, but radiologists
are here.
that our group has worked on is
with a diabetic Rhettinopathy.
say than Rhettinopathy.
diabetes are at risk and need to
be screened once a year.  This
is done by taking a picture of
back of the eye with a special
camera as you see here.  And the
picture looks a little bit like
that.
an image like this is they grade
it on a
from no disease so healthy to
the end stage B. they do
grading, they look for findings.
Little things called micro
anyou'rism that are out
pouchings in the blood guy.
That indicates how bad -- how
bad your diabeaties is affecting
your vision.
the world, there are not enough
eye doctors to do this task.
So in one of the -- with one of
our partners in India, a couple
of our
shortage of worn 27,000 eye
doctors in the nation.
As a result, about 45% of
suffer some vision loss before
the disease is detectd.  Again,
this is something that should
happening.
So what we decided to do is we
partnered with a couple of
hospitals in
a screening provider in the U.S.
and we got about  130,000 images
for this first go around.
hired 54 ophthalmologists and
built a labeling tool.
The opt mathatmologists made
this.interesting thing was that
there was actually variant and
how doctors call the images.
about 880,000 diagnosis in all.
With this label data set, we put
it
It is generally used to class
classify cats and dogs for our
photo.  So the other thing that
we learned really useful to have
this 5 point
diagnosis, it was also
incredibly
on housekeeping predictions like
image quality, whether this is a
left or right of the etna this
is.
So we added that to the network
as well.
This is the first version of our
model
journal in 2016, I believe.
And right here on the left is a
chart
and aggregate over about 10,000
images.
Sensitivity is on the right oop
-- on the Y access.
time when a parent has a disease
and you
the model was calling the
disease.  And then specificity
is the proportion
have the disease that the model
or doctor got right.  You can
see you want something with
sensitivity and high
specificity.  Up into the right
or up into the left is good.
here on the chart that the
little dots are the doctors that
were grading the same set.
and these are board certified
U.S. physicians.
are opt are opt  thatmologists,
general opt thatmologists by
training.
which are combined score, we're
just a
little better than the
meetingant particular study.  So
since then, we have improved the
model.
we were sort of on par with
generalists and then this year,
this is a new paper that we
published.
We actually used retina
specialists to grade the images.
So they're specialists.
argue when they guess
disagreed about what the
diagnosis was.
with the retina specialists.
This cappa thing is just
agreement on
see that essentially we're sort
of in
between the ophthalmologists and
retina specialists.
working on since beyond
improving the
have the networks explain how
it's making a prediction.
the consumer world, we started
using this technique called show
me where.
image we generate a heat map of
where the relevant pixels are
for this particular prediction.
here you can see a picture of a
pomeranian and the heat map
shows you
face of the pomeranian that make
its
look
pomeranian and on the right, you
have (inaudible) and the
networks highlighting the afghan
hound.
we applied it to the funded
images and we said show me
where.
and I can tell it's mild disease
-- normal to me.  I can't tell
there's any disease there.  But
a highly trained doctor would be
pick up little things called
micro aneurisms where the green
spots are.
moderate disease and this is a
little worse because you can see
some bleeding at the ends here.
actually, I don't know if I can
signal.  There's a bleeding
there and the heat
You can see that it picks up the
bleeding, but there's twoart
facts in this image.
is a dust spot on just like
little dark spot and then there
is this little of the image.
You can tell that a model just
ignores it essentially.
You train a model.  We showed
that it is some what
explainable.doing the right
thing.  What's next?
We actually have to deploy this
into systems and we're providing
them to
bring this to patients and
actually, Dr.
Jessgoing to speak after me.
Okay.  So I've given a screening
application diagnosis that we're
working on.
So, in this particular example,
we're
Lwe're talking about breast
cancer, but
midwesta size to nearby lymph
nodes.
diagnosed with breast cancer and
the
primary breast cancer isry
moved, the
taking out what we call lymph
nodes so
we can examine to see whether or
not the
breast cancer
messta sized in the lymph nodes.
Reading this is not an easy
task.
they went back to look at them,
this 24% had a change in noteo
status.
it was read negative.  If it was
negative, it was read positive.
that showed that a pathologist
with
unlimited time not overwhelmed
with data is quite
finding the tumors.
When you put time constraint on
the
pathologist, the sensitivity
drops.
And people start overlooking
where little disease may be.
one there.  That is usually
small things like this mixed.
This is not surprising given
that so much information is in
each slide.
Slides, if digitized is about 10
giga  pixels.
pathologists can find 73% of the
cancer fist they spend all their
time looking false positives.
So we train a model that can
help with this task.
cancer lesions and it has eight
false positives per slide.
is sensitive and also quite
specific that relies to look
over the false false positives.
working on  validation in a
clinic right
reader studies, how does it
actually interact with the
doctor is really quite
important.
there are applications to other
tissues and talk about lymph
nodes.
that
show this works for them.
can produce algorithms that are
very
make calls that a doctor might
already make half about
predicting things that  do for
imaging?  As recall in the
beginning of the
talk, one of the great things is
you can
very accurate algorithms without
writing rules.
So, this allows us to make
completely new discoveries.
paper that we published recently
where
models to predict cardio vas
cooler risk factors.
pressure, things that doctors
consider
right now to assess a patient's
cardio videos coolar risk.
So it turns thought we cannot
only
predict many of these factors
and quite
actually directly report a five
year risk of a cardiac's event.
preliminary and the AUC for this
prediction is .7.  What that
number means if given two
one picture of a patient that
did not have a cardiovascular
event and one did.
It is right about 70% of the
time.  Most doctor is around 50%
of the time.
to do based on the retinol image
alone.  So why is this exciting?
to assess your risk for
cardiovascular disease, there
are needles involved.
if anyone has gotten blood
cholesterol screening.  You fast
the night before and then we
blood samples and then assess
your risk.  Again, I want to
emphasize this is
these results support the idea
that we may be able to use
something like an predictions
that we couldn't make before.
This might be able to be done in
sort
manner.
examples of how deep learning
can really
availability and accuracy in
healthcare.  And one of the
things that I want to
acknowledge here is the reason
why this
has become more and more
exciting is, I tensorflow is
open source.
In kind of opens standard from a
I have given  examples, but
there's a
the community in other medical
centers that are very similar.
I am really excited about what
this technology can bring to the
field.
I would like to introduce Jess
Mega.
is a real doctor and a chief
medical doctorate kill burly.
all for being here and thank
you, Lily, for kicking us off.
think the excitement around AI
and healthcare could not be
greater.
As you heard, my name is Jess
Mega.
to be part of the Alphabet
family.Google X.  We focus
solely on healthcare and life
sciences.
health information and make it
useful so that patients live
healthier lives.
I'll talk about today focuses on
diabetes and really lends itself
to the started.  But I think
it's very important to pause and
think about health data broadly.
any individual who's in the
audience
today has about several
gigabytes of health data.think
about health in the years to
come
and think about genomix,
molecular
sensor dat apparent recorded
data, electronic health record
and claims,
of data and we're committed to
stay ahead of this so that we
can help patients.
some of our efforts on diabetes
is this issue.  About 1 in 10
people has diabetes.
When you have diabetes, it
affects how
glucose in the body.
If you think about
pre-diabetes, the
diabetes, that is 1 in 3 people.
That would be one entire section
of
have down stream effects.
You heard Lily talk about
diabetes retinopathy.
problems with their heart,
kidneys and neuropathy.  These
are the things we need to get
ahead of.We have two main issues
that we're trying to address.
The first one is an information
gap.
the most adherent parent with
diabetes and my grandfather was
one of these sugar four times a
day.  And I don't know if anyone
today has been age to have any
of the snacks.
had some of the caramel pop I
popcorn.  So if I didn't check
my glucose in wouldn't have
captured that data.  So we know
biology is happening all of the
time.
patients in the hospital, as a
cardiologist, I can see
someone's heart
and then people go home.  But
biology is still happening.
with diabetes.  The second issue
is a decision gap.  You may see
a care provider once a a year,
but health decisions are
happening every single day.
And how do we decide to close
this gap.
We're focusing on three key
missions be true for almost
every project we take on.  We're
thinking about how to shift from
reactive care to much more
proactive care.  In order to do
that and to get to the we can
use the power of AI, we have to
do three things.  We have to
think about collecting the
data and today I'll be talking
about continuous glucose
monitoring.
this data so that it is in a
forthat the that we can unlock
and activate and truly help
patients.
Whether we do this in the field
of
diabetes, this is the general
premise.
think about is the collection of
data.
You hear Lily say garbage in,
garbage out.
insights unless we understand
what we're looking at.
One thing is thinking about
extremely biocompatible
electronics.
So we are working on next
generation sensing.
to, for example, with extremely
small continuous glucose
monitors where we are
some of these tools, this will
lead to seemless integration.
we're understanding how your
body is handling sugar T. also
helps us understandna not only
happens at a population level,
but what might happen on an
individual level when certain
foods.  And the final thing is
to try to
reduce cost of dices so we can
democratize health.
of this data and I can speak
both as a
The thing people will say is
data is
with the tsunami of data.  You
need to organize it.
company called enduo.  The idea
is put the patient in the
diabetes managements.  This gets
to the heart of someone who is
going to be happier and
healthyef.What does that mean?
We try to empower people with
their glucose control.
diabetes association and see the
ranges that are recommended.
what you your day looks like.
Again giving a parent or a user
that
of their decisions and then
tracking
steps through Google fit.
how glucose is pairing with your
activity in your diet.here,
there's an app that prompts for
the photo of the food and then
using
Tensorflow we can identify the
food.  This is where the true
personal
because if you eat a certain
meal, it's helpful to understand
how your body ends up relating
to it.
preliminary data suggesting that
the
way I respond to a banana or you
might respond.  That's important
to know because all
those general recommendations
that we
make as a doc, if someone comes
to see
say here are the thins you need
to discount you need to watch
your diet,
exercise, you have to see your
foot doctor, primary care doctor
and foot
and that's a lot to integrate.
What we try to do is pair all of
this with a care lead.  This is
a person that helps someone on
If you look in the midst of what
I am
number of different lines.  I
want us to drill down and look
into that.
difference between the data you
might
see in an episodic glucose
example or
the continuous glucose monitor
enabled by this new sensing.
glucose monitor and look at a
cluster of days.  This is an
example.  We might start to see
patterns.
of thing a care lead or
physician would
through, but this is where you
start to unlock the power of
learning models.
can start to see is a cluster of
different mornings.
So maybe we'll make a positive
that everyone's eating
incredibly healthy here at
Google I/O.
mornings, but we go back into
our regular lives and eating a
different cluster of foods.
giving general advice, we can
use different models to point
out.
on with one patient, for
example, we were seeing a
cluster around Wednesdays.
Wednesdays?  Is it that the
person is going and stopping by
a particular location or a lot
of stress that day, but again
instead of giving general care,
we can
the most comprehensive and
actionable example.
So again, thinking about what
we're
and collecting data, organizing
it and then  activating it and
making it relevant.  So that is
the way we're thinking about
diabetes care and that is the
way work.  We heard this morning
in another discussion.  We have
tongue about the problems that
going to solve and use these
tools to really make a
difference.
can think about activating
information?
Lily that diabetic
retinoipalitysy one of the
leading causes of blindness.
excellent glucose care, there
may be times where you start to
have organ damage.
they end up affecting the fundus
and the retina.
Now, we know that people with
diabetes
undergo  screening, but earlier
in the talk, I gave you the
laundry list of
patients to do who have
diabetes.  So what we're trying
to do with this
figure out how do we actually
get ahead of the product and
think about an end to
that we realize and bring down
the challenges that exist today.
getting screened, one of it is
accessibility and one is having
access
ophthalmologists.
This is a problem in the United
States and in other parts of the
world.This is something we think
very globally about when we
think about the solution.
this idea that we can take
algorithms
sensitivity and specificity of
diagnosing diabeatic.
outlined.  The question is:  How
do we think about creating this
product because the
at places like Alphabet and
working at partners like you all
here today, we can
problem we're solving and create
the algorithms, but we need to
step back and
to create in the space of
healthcare and life science.
We need to think about the image
and delivering that.
So what we're doing is taking
this
our  partners.  There's a
promising pilot that's
as in India and we're so
encouraged to hear the early
feedback.
I wanted to share with you.
One is that looking at this
early
accuracy with  AI than with the
manual greater.
And the thing that's important
as a don't know if there are any
other doctors in the room, but
the piece I
to be room for healthcare
providers.
What the tools are doing is help
with the job.Technology and AI
going to replace physicians or
replace the healthcare system.
about it, it just augments the
work we do.
If you think about the
stethoscope and about 200 years
ago, it doesn't  replaced work
we do.  It merely augments the
work we do.think you are going
to see a similar theme as you
continue to think about
more effective way to bring
about patients.
And then the second thing is to
think of that base of patients.
How do we truly democratize
care?
The other encouraging piece from
the pilot was this idea that we
can start to parents treated
with the algorithm.
Now, I would love to say it is
really
turns out it takes a huge
village to do this kind of work.
So what's next?path to clinical
adoption?  This is what makes it
incredibly
so many wonderful technologists
and engineers.  We need to
partner with clinical sites
here.
We also partner deeply with the
FDA as
well as regulatory agencies in
Europe and beyond.
thing we decided to do was be
part of the FDA
pre-certification program.
technologies is  critical, but
we need to figure out how to do
that in ways
effective.
I am grateful for Alphabet for
staying with it.
partners like Night Count and
Optus.
They come together to transform
care.
opportunity not only in
diabetes, but really in this
entire world of health
information.interesting to think
about it as a physician who
spends most of my time
taking care of fahrenheits
Fahrenheits in the hospital --
patients in the hospital.
we stay ahead of it, we can
close this gap.
We can figure out ways to become
more preventative.
can collect the right
information.  We can create the
infrastructure and
figure out how to activate it.
the type of work to do alone.
and we at Google and Alphabet
look forward to partnering with
you.  Please help us on this
journey.Lily and I will be here
after these talks.  We're happy
to chat with all of you
spending time at I/O.
4:30-5:30 p.m.
Integrating your content with
the
>> Oh, thanks.
I'm so glad you can make it
today to
super awesome Google I/O.
>> BARRIE LEVINSON: And I am
Barrie,
to find your content and use it
on Google Assistant.
And today, we're here tocontent
is reach millions of devices on
Google Assistant really without
much work at all for you.
refresher, but just a quick
overview of presents itself to
you with Google Assistant.
Assistant really helps people
get
over 1 million actions, actions
is the word that we use to
describe things that assistant
can do.
And assistant is ready to help
wherever users are.
With over 500 million Voice
activated
like Google home, eligible
mobile phones and are the
devices where Google Assistant
work.
available across the globe and
more
than 25 locales and in 80
countries and 30 languages.
that's a lot of devices and a
lot of
actions that assistant can do
and a lot  for your content.
How you can bring your site's
content into this Eco system.
presented ways for you to
optimize content for search
since what my kids
would call the 1900s.sites with
content and popular areas like
news, podcasts and recipes, the
optimizations that you have
likely made
already for search will also
help your
discoverable in Google
Assistant.  So we'll be
explaining how to use
content to help drive traffic to
your
site for both assistant and for
search
the same work on your part.
accessing with different kinds
of use
We than users are -- we than
users are
commute  routines and then in
the
evening around meal preparation,
recipe
Google has put a lot of thought
how to
different kinds of use cases.
conversation with Google
Assistant
done in my world.
Let's take for example Zach at
the center of his world.
latest hep seed of his podcast.
If he's not sure what he wants
to
different pod casts to try.
At dinner time when Zach is hung
rye
make, she asks his assistant for
ideas.  They are easy is to
browse and load
single tap, he can choose a food
that sends straight to his
Google home.
worry about handling his phone
in the
kitchen when he might be busy
using his
whatever it is he's making for
dinner.  And Google Assistant is
there
with lots of other use cases too
like
reading the news, translations,
getting
through photos and more.  So
let's have a look at how some
like Zach and many others
throughout the day.
Here are three examples.
produce scaro sills and rich
results in
a Voice activated device to hear
of a
news or listen to a podcast or
find a recipe.connected to
content right away.
On the left, a user is asking
for top
right away gets a carousel of
the latest headlines.
Rendered quickly with nice
imagery.
middle, a user is asking for and
gets recipes from food network.
recipe to send straight to
Google Google Home.
assistant to play Planet Money.
You might know that the actions
each in every action that users
can do on assistant.
When recipe podcasts and news
optimize your content using
structured
data, you become eligible for an
auto in the actions directory.
The actions directory is
organized
and it's also organized by
things that
users are trying to do like find
food recipes or play a podcast.
content could be presented in
multiple
depending what  users are trying
to do.
We built the actions directory
to be single tap from Google
Assistant like
you see here on mobile and
there's also
available on the desk top and
also for mobile browsers.
promote your action or your
current users can share it with
their friends or with their
followers.
can choose to do to get your
content  assistant.
Structured data and AMP are key
to optimizing for search and for
assistant the same work to do
both.  When you invest in
structured data,
devices and help users get
things done throughout their
day.
structured data can make your
content
eligible for coo ruseels and
rich results like you just saw.
And for a page on the actions
directory.  When you further
enhance your content
your mobile pages to load
quickly and
take advantage of Google AMP
cache.take things further and
claim your actions directory
page to make it your
additional features like user
reviews.  And you can consider
going furt are to
custom action using the actions
on Google developer platform.
We'll cover all three in the
take.
mark up and AMP a few times
already and we're all on the
same page about that.
AMP stands for accelerated
mobile
an indication that this will
load quickly and smoothly B.
retrieve its from Google AMP
cache which has a variety of
optimizations.
data mark up on the web to best
understand the content on each
and every page.
up is a standardized format for
specifying information about a
page and classifying it.
have a recipe page, what are the
ingredients, the cook time,
nutrition information and so on.
help Google search understand
content on your pages by giving
crew clues that
to stands.  They're really well
documented standards for
structured dat that vary
and the standards are consistent
with open standards for schema.
org.
examples for news, podcasts and
recipes today.
specify your structured data for
web pages.
JavaScript, open notation with
linked data is  encoding that's
used by graph.
JSON LD shows ahead of each page
and starts with a script tag
that says hey,
the JavaScript that contains
some JSON LD.
So this really simple snippet of
mark website type.  I'm using
the vocabulary there  schema.
org and the website has this
URL.Another implementation of
mark up would be with  HTML
extensions that places
throughout the page with tagged
attributes that name the
properties and
in the head and body of the
structures.  We will see a
preferred method to use
you can also use Google's
examples to
create your JSON  LD mark up
rather than scratch.
we will use a case study example
of a family recipe site.
Structured data mask up and AMP
works
for large publishers like good
network
anyone including a small family
recipe site.  In fact, this is
not just any small
This is my own family's recipe
site.
Recently, my husband and I
optimized site.  So there are
few characters in the story.  So
I can follow along in the plot.
(inaudible).  You might know
that it is a dutch
cookie with some carra mel
inside of some waffles.It will
show up in some pictures.
And then Saunders
coach trough is waffles and cort
the site owner and he's also
dutch.
you see here in the carousel
including a Saunders strove
waffles.
you ask Google assistant to find
recipes from cort adventure.
You can send it to your Google
home.
after -- so here's the before
and after with our recipe site.
Before we made changes for
structured data, a page like on
the left would show
specific query for Saunders
dutch recipe.
There is pretty ordinary search
result
and unremarkable text.  We
started to participate in rich
And you can spot a few more
differences.  Because of
structured data mark ups,
smarter about the data that it
finds on our site and on this
page.  The generic blue link is
gone.You can see a row of chips
to select
relevant content under title
recipes.
our recipe  content of course
from the way the data is passed
in the mark up.
data mark up for recipes, we
were age to increase discovery
for search and for
the same time with exactly the
same work.  And true story.
e-mail.
So it's like last week from
Google
small had increased more than
300% in
the month of April with 72% of
user
through offering antic search --
organic search.  So after our
site was indexed and converted
to structured data, we noticed a
page in the actions direct we.
actions directory page for food
network
and this is the actions
directory page
rendered on web browser or
desktop.  Later on we'll so how
this page can be
to customize it with our own
images and information.
takes to use structured data
narc up and
code and we'll continue to use
the
family recipe site as an
example.
structured data snippet for type
recipe.
structured data guidelines, you
will need to follow the specific
guidelines
type that you have in order to
be eligible in rich  results
displays in both search and
assistant.
org vocabulary as I mentioned.
what is required by schema.org.
So Google is able to read JSON
data
injected into a page's content
and that's what we're doing in
the family recipes site
architecture.
Here the server site PHP helps
generate
an AMP recipe page using recipe
details
of the my SQL database.  When it
is requested by the web
database for the recipe details,
then
marks it up as HTML and return
its to a
This also insists the structured
data we
added the injuriesson inside the
script head.  So the highlighted
part is the essence of what is
new after optimizing with the
data mark up.  Obviously for
recipe collection, the
type of structured data we use
was the type.
So let's have a closer look at
that.  This is the first section
of mark up
recipe specifically Saunders
dutch strobe waffles.  Each page
carries mark up specific to it.
we see the result of where the
recipe information is pulld to
generate mark up.
you can easily parse the
resulting mark
up and see the name,
description, I'mor,
time and cook time.  The format
is always expressed as a set of
attribute value pairs.
Saunders.strobe waffles.  You
use the recipe for a single
recipe at a time.
recipes or a whole list.
And there are 15 total recipe
properties that are recommended.
Although only name is actually
required.  Going into this, we
didn't have an in the
collection.  So that is
something we're working on.
the block of mark up for a photo
that
would be for the big stack of
GUI strobe waffles.
same recipe page, we have
ratings.
data, we added ratings to the
site, which isn't something that
had been a feature before.see
here the mark up for ratings
that includes data for the
rating value, a
best and worse rating for the
recipe page.
ratings will render in search
results.
result of adding the structured
data mark up for data ratings on
the page.
the rating, et cetera.  And now
the last part of the mark up
rest of the format truncated a
little bit to fit on the slide.
and finally, the nutrition
information.  So for us
nutrition information was
database, but many of the fields
were empty.  So adding more data
has been a good enhancement
here.Then at the end, we closed
the script and now you have seen
the full format
the recipe, for the type recipe.
The structured data testing tool
helps
correct to standards for
whatever type you're using.
to use.  It's open.  You can
find it easily on Google
search and puts a running page
URL.
the tool shows any anomalies as
compared to the standards for
the type that I'm testing.
can see here I have an error
where the cook time was
formatted in some way that
person as compared to the ISO
format
and fix errors one at a time and
it would be recommended to do
this really
pages to check the format.
site optimization process was
structured data.
the structured data guidelines
to create the mark up using JSON
LD.
documented examples rather than
starting from scratch.  We
validate our code using the
testing  which is probably going
to be anities rative process
where you find and fix errors.
unblock robots.text which might
keep the crawlers from getting
to your mark up.
monitor errors and reindex the
site as you change it.
special about using structured
data mark
for news content.  Let's have a
along.
There's a special type news
article
that are recommended in the case
of
non-AMP pages, the headline and
the image is highlighted.news
articles when you are optimizing
with AMP mobile pages,
additional
and those include the publisher,
publisher name, the logo,  URL,
date
here on the next slide.
When AMP pagesna have structured
data
dat can appear in a carousel of
stories like the ones you saw
from the New York Times earlier.
Without the structured  data,
AMP pages
can load fast, but they would
show up as links in search
results.  Also for news content
Fyou offer subscription based
access to your
or if users need to register for
access, there's a guideline
that's specific to
structured data for subscription
and pay walled content.  If your
site is marked up with
data and AMP following the
standards for the type news
article and also follows
index guides, you can apply to
be in Google news.
So now I will hand it to Zach to
talk
podcast content.
Let's walk through an example.
cast appears in the actions
directory.  And Google search
which was all mark up.
By structuring your podcast
content,
search results and descriptions
and even on embedded player for
each episode.
content may be automatically
turned into an action on the
Google assistant with a the
actions directory.  In order for
your podcast to be properly
indexed, we need to first
valid RSS feed, and have 2.0
specifications and insure your
feed
dedicate home page that points
to your RSS feed.
We'll now cover the certainly
podcast
episode level and mark up
requirements to make sure your
content is set up for success.
shows the podcast level tags
that need to get configured.
This takes us for planet money
podcast.
Make sure you have a tag that
defines your podcast title.
other requirements are tags that
define your podcast home page
along with
cover next.  Optionally, you can
also add tags that state the
author, description, image, and
language for your podcast.
-for-per these are the rip seed
level
that would need to get
configured.  The only two
requirements are the
enclosure tag which points to
the URL.  Optionally, you can
also configure a
publication date, duration and
more for each episode.
The last step is to make sure
that  has a home page that very
clearly
describes what the podcast is
is.
link that points to your podcast
RSS URL.
Once that is all set up, you are
on
Google search and Google
Assistant just
by  configuring a few RSS tags.
reviewed structured data mark
up.  Now the best big
opportunity is to claim your
page.
your action will unlock three
key cape ability for you.  First
the ability to modify your
Second the ability to view
Analytics on your actions
performance and then
opportunity for improved ranking
and discovery.
Barrie's content.
Once it is made, you will be
able to action by creating a
project on the actions on Google
developer console
creating, managing and
optimizing your actions.  Shown
here the actions on Google  is
the place where you will be able
to manage your actions after you
claim them.
you will notice there's a
dedicated section for you to
modify your directory
information.use the console to
change up images and
descriptions to more accurately
reflect actions and its content.
claimed, you will be able to
view them in the console.
console can help to you monitor
your actions star ratings along
with directory page use.
claimed actions, users will have
the ability to rate and submit
written
This is all access using the
actions directory.  So for
example, this is how ratings
will appear on the directory
page for Barrie's content.
Many are quality indicateors.
importantly, they're benchmarks
that users depend on for
relevant  feedback.
functionality is accessible by
using
Now that we just covered
claiming your action, let's
discuss by how  conversational
action.
You can take action that actions
on
to offer.
optimize your existing content
for a
or you can decide to build
custom actions with a much more
conversational AI focus.
advantage of the Google
assistant, the best path is to
build a custom conversational
action.
discuss a thought process,
rationale and overview of
creating these custom actions.
will most likely need to revisit
your contents identity for the
AI first world.need more than
just  graphics.  It will need a
fully developed  personality.
example, is your content funny
or serious?  What Voice will
represent your content?
tailor the personality of your
action to stand out in a
conversational environment?
just looking to access your
website in an audio form.  The
more rich your conversational
more we can suggest your action
to increase discovery.
Assistant learns from other
about which actions may be best
for assisting the user with
their needs.
includeior brands name, your
content may be recommended to
the user.
actions that provide users with
a really high quality end user
experience and the create this
more tailored branded
experience is create a custom
action from scratch.
many providers have elected to
go the custom action rout.  We
have been working with partners
food network to enhance custom
actions.
custom action is triggered.
just started an episode of the
pioneer woman.
and dives is coming on at 11:00
a.m. Pacific.
You can ask for details or for
recipes.would you like?
>> Recipes from the biopeer
woman
pioneer woman.
address.   Delish.  What else
can I help you with?
conversational action which you
just
find inspiration in the kitchen
across
devices with those displays and
surfaces such as Google home.
favorite chefs and shows, but
send recipes via email.network
customizes their content for
conversational world and creates
several reengagement.  First
users can ask when the show is
on air.
currently being prepared and
then they'll have the ability to
share the
to enjoy later.  All elements
are usually woven
together in a coherent thread
that includes content.
anticipates their behavior.
developer console which makes it
easier than ever to create
custom actions for your content.
you create a project, you can
choose from several categories
that will tailor your workflow.
whether you are a podcast
provider
followers, the actions on Google
developer is the place to get
started.
you through different stages of
development.  Build actions that
will help users get with the
information they both want and
need and then test your actions
either
the new dweeb simulator to run
through user flows.  Deploy your
actions or to limited
Beta audiences and then finally,
measure the success of your
actions with
on usage, errors and intoe
channels.
It's sizasm as set up, build,
test, deploy and measure.There
are numerous surfaces that you
can
target with your custom actions
outfut and those with screen
output.
experience based on the device
being used.  For devices with
screens including
or smart displays, you can have
special responses that take
advantage of the screen.
podcast provider, show images
that can play inside the audio.
optimize for the eyes and hands
free experiences that  speakers
have to offer.getting ready in
the morning or running out the
door to commute to and from
work.
the 80 to interact with the
display.  Users won't have the
time to blouse website if they
need to keep their eyes on
something else or if their hands
are full.critical opportunities
throughout a users day that
you'll be able to present
information such as news stories
or a brand new episode of your
podcast.
leveraging latest advances in
machine learning, AI and natural
language Google's technology
stack to create a really
advanced assistive experience
and
this power while creating your
actions in a multitude of ways.
opportunities.
You can use a vast array of
cards in
for your content.  You can also
leverage speed synthesis
responses even more lifelike.
Then play around with our brand
themed content visual appearance
especially on
some of our beautiful, new smart
displays.
example of a Barrie's custom
action by leveraging themed
customizations that actions
developer  console.
This is an awesome opportunity
for
the full recipe to human the
content stand out.  Actions are
personal.
allow you to use Google
assistance along side count
linking and user experiences for
individual users of your
actions.  If you're a content
provider, it special opportunity
for you to interact with your
users.
provide personalized podcast,
recipe and news story
recommendations.
assistant to augment the
consumption experience.
information about guests and
stories being discussed on a
given episode F.
use Google Assistant to help
provide them with  aughtments
information about
places being discussed along
with relevant recommendation
such as articles and news
stories.
Barrie can also leverage
personallations for her recipe
content.
users name and location.
Suppose Barrie wants to suggest
where
ingredients and supplies for her
recipe, she can suggest common
drinks and sides that will go
well with the recipe.  She can
then use localization in a of
languages.  Actions are
reengaging.  With custom
conversational actions,
s to share, RL that would have
them directly to the action.
about upcoming shows, stories
and special events  using push
notifications.
also allow to send daily
recommendations to her users.
By taking advantage of the
you can leverage to allow them
to
purchase premium content,
American an
-- American an dice or order
digital goods.  And there's
much, much more.
there's always room to grow with
custom conversational actions.
AMP allows to you take existing
web
for Google search and Google
Assistant.  You will be eligible
for having a page directory.  In
fact, many of you have already
completed the necessary mark up
for your content.so, you will
notice there is already a page
in the directory to claim your
action.
claim your directory listing,
view
Analytics and receive  ratings
for your content.
to go above and beyond the
limitations of mark up, visit
the actions on Google
create a custom conversational
action.
Doing so will allow you to do
many
reengagement and transactional
features
in APIs as you build out your
custom actions.opportunities for
what you can create
for your content are truly
endless.
what you can build with custom
conversational actions to
leverage the
Google and Google assist ants
Google Assistant.
If you haven't done so, there
are  things done during the day.
To see some really awesome demos
Sandbox.
Thank you and we hope you all
continue to have a really great
Google I/O.
5:30-6:30 PST
Stage 7
Alternative architectures for
your PWA
>> JEFF: So, hello, everybody.
Ha, my name is Jeff Posnick and
I'm a
developer relations team.
So I'm here to talk about
an an important but potentially
topic.  Your architecture
decisions come into play when
you are building a progressive
web app.
what do I mean by web architect
architecture?  One way to think
about it is to ask following
questions.  When a user visits a
page on my site, what HTML is
loaded?
loaded when they visit another
page?
The answers to those questions
are not forward.  When you start
thinking about progressive web
apps, they get complicated.
to walk you through one possible
architecture that I found
effective.
label the decisions that I made
as being my approach for
building a progressive
webfree to use my approach when
building your own PWA, but at
the same time,
alternatives as well.  My hope
is that by seeing how all the
and you you will go out and
customize
everything to suit your own
particular needs.
ended up building to this talk
is a
StackOverflow of PWA.
contributing to StackOverflow
and I wanted to build a web app
that would
browse through for a given
topic.
It is built on top of the public
stack
out live and use the URLs on
that slide.
how I built that web app, let's
define pieces of terminology.
First, we'll talk about
multi-page
apps or MPAs.
as a fancy name for the
traditional architecture that's
been used since the beginning of
the web.
Each time a user navigates to a
new UR
L, they are going to browse
specific to that page.no attempt
to preserve the pages states
or the content in between
navigations.
a new page, you are starting
fresh.
This is in contrast to the
single page
web apps in which the browser
runs Java web app code when the
user visits a new section.
SPAs and MPAs are equally veiled
models for you to use but for
this talk, I
within the content of a
multi-page app, something we
haven't talked about too much in
the past.
countless otherses the phrase
progressive web app or PWA.
what do I mean by that exactly?
You can think of a PWA as a web
app
experience and earns a place
under the user home screen.
fast, integrated reliable and
engaging.  The purposes of this
talk however
a subset of those attributes
fast and reliable.
different content.
loading as little as possible
from the network.  The raw speed
isn't enough.
a  PWA, your web app should be
reliable.  Needs to be
resilient, enough to
even if it's just a customized
error page regardless of the
state of the network.
we're going to rephrase the PWA
definition slightly and look at
what it reliably fast.  Now it
is not good enough to be fast
and reliable only when you're on
a low network.  Being reliably
fast means that your web app
speed is consistent regardless
network conditions.
So PWAs introduce a high bar for
speed and resilience.
building blocks to make that
type of
performance a reality.
cache storage API.
So a service worker sits in
between
a as a proxy.  What that service
worker does is completely up to
you.
The service taker takes incoming
requests and forwards them on to
the network.then returns the
network response to page as is.
This trivial service worker
doesn't
versus the default value.
But once we add the cache
storage API
workers shine through.  So we
can build service worker that
before, passing some on to the
network.  Instead of just
returning the network
we can write a service worker
that
stores a copy of the response
for future
storage API.
Next time the web app makes that
request, it can check the cashes
and
45eously cache response.
So a void the network whenever
reliably fast performance.
cover is what sometimes referred
to Java script.  Simply put,
it's the ideana the same Java
script code can be shared
between
run time environments.
So when I build my PWA, I wanted
to
end server and the service
worker.  There are lots of valid
approaches to
but the approach that worked for
me was
to use EFs modules as a
definitive source.
d and for the service worker in
babble and roll up.
So in my Slides when you see an
MJ extension, we're  talking
about code
that lives in an ES module.
terminology in mind, let's dive
into the StackOverflow of PWA.
start by covering our back end
server and explain how that fits
into the overall architecture.
dynamic back ends along with
static
approach was used to Firebase
platform.
Firebase Cloud functions will
based environment when there's
an incoming request and
integrates with a
HTB framework which is already
familiar with.  It also offers
out of the box hosting
site statin assets and let's
take a look
at how that server handles
incoming requests.
request against our server, it
goes flow.
The server routs the request
based on
the  URL and it uses templating
logic to
to create a complete HTML
document.  We use a combination
of data from the
well as partial HTML fragments
that the server  stores locally.
we start streaming HTML back to
our web app.  So there are two
pieces of this  in more detail.
Routing and templateing.
When it comes to routing, my
approach
express frameworks Native
routing Syntax.  It is flexible
enough to match simple
well as URLs that include
parameters
such as the question ID as part
of the path.
earlyish, we're  using ES
modules as a
source of truth and Java code.
directly from the service code.
given express pattern, the
appropriate handler with
templating logic specific
a chance to respond.
They piece together fragments in
sequence one after another.
itself really well to streaming
response back.
The several sends back initial
HTML
immediately and the browse Serb
able to
render that nationalphage page
right away.
Testimony  It streams them till
the document is complete.
take a look at the express code
from one
of our routs.
using the responses right method
and referencing locally stored
partial start the response
stream immediately without
blocking on any sort of external
data source.
and renders a meaningful
database and away.
So that loading please wait
message
givers important context to our
users,
the sort of thing you expect to
see in a multi-page app.  Rather
than rely on JavaScript, I am
the empty pseudoclass in  CSS to
display that message and then it
will
content starts streaming in.  So
going back to our rout handler.
data from the stack exchange
API.  Getting that data means
that our
request.  We can't render
anything else until we get a
response back and process it.
users are not staring at a blank
screen while they wait.
stack exchange API, we call
custom templating function to
translate the dat
corresponding HTML.
contentious  topic.
here is one approach among many.
You will want to substitute your
own
you have Legacy ties to an
existing templating framework.
But what made sense for my use
case
to just rely on  JavaScripts
template literals with some
logic broken out into functions.
So one of the nice  things about
building an MPA is that we don't
have to track of state updates
and rerender our  HTML as things
change.
HTML worked fine for me.  All
right.  Soy here's an example of
how I am
portion of our web apps index.
As with our routs, the
templating
that can be imported into both
the
server and the service worker.
And just a reminder.
you are  taking user provided
input and converting it into an
HTMLit is crucial escape
dangerous character sequences.
If you are using existing
templating
rolling your own, then it might
be taken care of for you.  Okay.
pure JavaScript is used to break
out into larger helpful
functions when appropriate.
each of the items returned in
the API
response into one such function.
element with all attributes set.
A particular note is a data
attribute
each link set to the stack
exchange  API
corresponding question --
display the corresponding
question.  Keep it in mind.later
on.  Okay.
Once templating is complete, we
stream
of our pages HTML to the browser
and we end the stream.
progressive rendering is
complete.
So that's a brief tour of our
servish set up.
first time will always get a
response
from the server, but when a
visitor
the service worker will get a
chance to start responding.
Let's dive in there.
familiar.  Many of the same
pieces we previously
are here in slightly different
arrangement.  Let's walk through
the requests flow
worker taking all the logic into
account.
So service worker handles an
incoming
request for a give everyone URL.
Just like our server did, it
does
figure out how to response.
The approach is the same as
before but
primitives like fetch and the
cache storage API.  We use those
data sources to construct
HTML response, which the service
worker
passes back to the web page.
scratch, with those low level
service worker on top of a set
of high
level  librarys called Workbox.
the Workbox engineering team and
this is not exactly  unbiased.
provides a solid foundation for
any
service worker's caching,
routing and
Throughout the next set of
Slides, we'll
see how Workbox is put to use.
routing.  Just as with our
server side code, our
worker needs to know how to
match up an incoming request
with the appropriate response
logic.
approach was to translate each
express
rout into a corresponding
regular
helpful library called ridge X
per M.  Once that translation is
performed, we
Workbox's bottom and support for
regular expression routing.
has our regular expressions, we
register
Workbox's router.
Inside each rout, we're able to
provide custom templating logic
used to a response.  Tim
operating in the service worker
is a bit more involved than it
was in our
The Workbox helps with a lot of
the heavy lifting.
that our partial HTML templates
are locally available in the
cache storage API.
up to date whenever we deploy
changes to the web app.
done by hand.  We turn to
Workbox to handle
precaching as part of our build
process.
precache and using a
configuration file pointing to
the directory that contains
assets along with the set of
patterns to match.
The file is automatically read
by the
is run each time we rebuild our
sites
as part of my build process.
of each file's content and
automatically injects that list
of URLs and  revisions
final service worker file.
Workbox now has everything it
needs to
always available and always kept
up to date.  For folks who use a
more complex build
Workbox has a node and in
addition to the command line.
stream that pre-cast partial
HFML back
immediately without any delays.
This is a really crucial part of
being reliably fast.
get something meaningful on the
screen right away.
Fortunately, using the stream's
API
service worker makes that
possible.  Now, you might have
heard about the
streams API before.
colleague Jake Archibald has
been singing the  phrases for
years.back in 2016.  And the
stream's API is awesome today
difference.  While only Chrome
supported the streams back then,
the streams API much supported
now.  All right.
So careful observers might note
that asterisk.
yachts for today -- car yachts
for caveats for today.
You can make that change.
also a known bug that lead to
issues
with edges current streams
implementation.
story is positive and with
appropriate  fallback code,
there is nothing stopping
streams in your service worker
today.
Well, well the thigh be one
thing
wrapping your head around how
the
streams  API actually works.
primitives and developers who
are comfortable using it can
create really complex Dataflows.
understanding the full
implication of code similar to
what's on the screen for
everyone.  Rather than parse
through this logic, let's talk
about my approach to service
So I'm using a brand new high
level  wrapper provided by
Workbox.
a mix of streaming sources from
cashes and run time data that
might come from the network.
will take care of coordinating
the individual sources and
stitching them
streaming response.
More over, Workbox detects
whether the streams API is
support and when it's  it
creates an, 85 leapt of
non-streaming response -- an
equivalent of non-streaming
response.doesn't mean you have
to worry about
writing fallbacks to 100%
browser    All right.  Let's
turn our attention to how our
We are making use of Workboxes
for a scale while we validate
along with
sure storage doesn't grow
unbounded.
Let's take a look how those
concepts translate into code.
Workbox to handle the different
sources
final streaming response.  A few
function calls and some
would otherwise take hundreds or
thousands of lines of hand
written code.
will be used to read data that's
been
pre-cached like our partial HTML
templates.
strategy implements that steal
while we
implement that scale while we
validate reentries.have those
strategies in place, all
that's left is to tell Workbox
how to
We pass in an array of sources
as functions and each of those
functions
Workbox takes the result from
each
source and stream its to the web
app in only delaying if the next
function in
the array hasn't completed yet.
pre-cached partial templates
that read
So they'll always be available
immediately.
implementation will be reliably
fast and responding to requests
just like our server side code
was.
Our next sorts function fetches
data and  processes the response
into the
that our web app expects.  The
scale revalidates strategy means
call and will be able to stream
into the call immediately while
updating the
background for the next time
that it's requested.
of our footer, enclose the final
HTML
service worker code, certain
bits hopefully look familiar.
The partial HTML and the
template used
by the service worker is
identical to
handler uses.  This code sharing
insures that users
get a consistent experience
whether they visiting the web
app for the first time or
returning to a page that's been
worker.
That's the beauty of using
isoforfix
So we have walked through both
the
server and the service worker,
but of logic.  There's a small
Java script that runs on each of
our pages after they're fully
in.  This code progressively
roan Hanses
the user -- enhances the user
So one thing we're using that
for is metadata baseed on the
API response.end up using the
same initial bit of
cache to HTML for each page, we
end up
the documents head, but the
coordination between the
templating and our client
the windows title  using page
specific metadata.
So as part of the templating
code, we
a script tag containing the
properly escaped string.
Then once the page is load, we
read in and update the document
title.  Now if there are other
pieces of page
update your own web app and you
can follow the same approach.
enhancement we added is use used
to offline capabilities.
We have built a reliable PWA.
We want users to know when
they're
they can revisit previously
visited pages.
We do this in two stages.
storage API from within the
content of the client side
JavaScript.
previously cached API requested
and
transfer that into a list of
URLs.
attribute we talked about
containing the
URL for the API request needed
to display the request?
attributes against the list of
cache
all the question linksna that
don't match.  This gives us all
the data we need to handlers and
respond to the browser
going online or offline.
state, we loop through the list
of uncached links and give out
the ones that don't work.
mind this is just a visual hint
so user about what they should
expect from those pages.
disabling the links or
preventing the user from
navigating.
we restore the links to the
original capacity.
my approach to building a
multi-page PWA.factors you will
have to consider when coming up
with your own approach and you
different choices than I did.
And that flexibility is one the
great
But there are few common
pitfalls that you may encounter
when making your own decisions
and I wanted to call them out
in advance to hopefully save you
some pain.
would really recommend against
storing
complete HTML documents in your
cache.a waste of space.
If your web app uses the same
basic structure for each of its
pages, you end up storing copies
of the same mark up again and
again.
deploy a change to the sates
shared HTML structure.  Each one
of those previously cache
still stuck with your old
layout.  You can imagine the
frustration when
and see a mix of old and new
pages  depending upon whether
they previously
So the other pitfall to avoid
involves your server and your
service worker getting out of
sync.
JavaScript so the code was
always run in both places.
depending upon your existing
server
architecture, that's not always
possible.
architectural decision you end
up making, you need to have some
strategy
ruleing and template and code in
your
server and your service worker.
those pitfalls?
Well, all sorts of failures are
the worst case scenario is that
a user
returns to your site and
navigates around.
revisiting a cache page for the
very stale layout.  So it's
jarring when you see it during a
presentation and it is just as
interacting for your web apps
repeat visitors.
everything you can to avoid
this.
Alternative  Alternatively, they
might come across
that is run by your server.
Zombie layouts and ruleing dead
ends
reliable PWA.  But you're not in
this alone.
The following tips can help you
avoid those pitfalls.Try to use
templating and routing
libraries that have JavaScript
implementations.
every developer has a luxury of
migrating off the current web
server and
number of popular templating and
routing frameworks have
implementations in multiple
languages.You can find one that
works with
JavaScript as well as your
current servers language.step
closer to keeping your service
worker and your server in sync.
sequential templates that can be
It's okay if later portions of
your page use more complicated
templating
you stream in the initial parts
of your
HTML as quickly as possible.
should  pre-cache all of your
sites critical static
resources.
a run time  caching rout to
handle dynamic content like  API
requests.
means you can build on top of
well tested production ready
strategies
from scratch.   Related to, that
you should only block on the
network when it's not
to stream a response from the
cache.  Diss playing a cache API
responds
to a better user experience than
waits for that fresh data.
s that I covered today, you're
on your
way to build a first class  PWA
experience.
that's fast, loading as little
as possible from the network and
the casing
all the bytes for loading were
for
actual content with almost no
overhead.
that's reliable by displaying
something meaning.  Even when
you're offline.
queues to reenforcing that we're
providing a reliable experience.
reliably fast by streaming in
our initial HTML immediately.
regardless of the network
conditions.
We're interested in your
feedback on this presentation.
Please go to the website or use
the
Android I/O S
iOS  apps.
Thank you and special thanks to
everybody here in person.
at the web Sandbox area
afterwards and I would really
love to chat.  So thanks again.
Cheers.